(upbeat music)
(Joey groans)
- Trash Taste.
(Connor groans)
(relaxing music)
Hello, you fabulous fun bags.
Welcome back to another episode
of Trash Taste podcast.
- Oh, god.
- Oh my god.
- I'm fun bag number one
with fun bag number two and three.
- Are you filling fun today, Joey?
- I'm feeling super fun today.
- I gotta say, you kinda look
like fucking Rocky Balboa
about to run up those steps right now.
(Joey screams)
- That is a very sports-like jumper.
- Is it?
- It does look like the
stereotypical I'm about to montage.
- I walked in the office and
Meilyne called me a fuck boy.
I don't know if I appreciated that or not.
- It's because you have
short hair and a beanie.
- It's the short hair, beanie,
and the rings, I don't know.
- You shaved your facial hair.
- Yeah, we all did.
- For the charity stream
that we just finished.
- People are gonna be like,
oh my god, this episode's so,
they recorded this so long ago.
- Yeah, I know. (laughs)
Really dating ourselves.
We're like, yeah, we just
recorded the charity stream,
which was probably-
- For you guys was like a month ago.
For us, it was two days ago.
- I think it was a month
and a half ago, right?
- Yeah.
- Oh, more than that, yeah.
- Yeah, we're trying to get ahead
before we fly off once again.
- But yeah, if you guys
didn't know about it,
we just finished a 24-hour charity stream
for Doctors Without Borders,
and it was extremely successful.
- Yeah, I was very surprised.
We raised 176,
but we haven't added the amounts-
- It's about 180, I think, total.
- About 180, adding everything
that we collected in total.
- That's crazy.
- That's nuts.
- Crazy.
- Which is absolutely fucking nuts.
I don't know what we expected
out of this charity stream.
- There was a part of me
when we were deciding,
okay, what are we gonna make our goal?
And someone was like 100,000.
I was like, in 24, that's
a lot of money, dude.
- Yeah, maybe if we are like doing
a week-long subathon maybe.
- Yeah, or something like that.
'Cause I don't know, I only
did one charity stream once,
years and years ago with Aki,
and we did not raise
nearly that much money.
I think, in the back of my head,
I had that as my benchmark.
So when I heard a 100,000, I was like,
dude, we're not fucking
PewDiePie or Jacksepticeye.
We're not gonna hit those numbers.
Turns out, we kinda did,
because we were number one
on Twitch for that night.
Which was nuts.
- Yeah, yeah, I mean,
I think we peaked at 53,000
viewers, which is insane.
- PB.
- Quite a lot.
- Yeah, personal best, personal best.
That's definitely the most
I've been involved in.
- It's definitely the most I've had, yeah.
- Definitely by far.
Well, I'm not even the streamer.
So that's definitely the
most I've been a part of.
- Yeah, it's just ridiculous.
- But how was the experience for you boys?
- You know what?
Even though I went into
it with zero sleep,
it was probably the most fun
stream I've ever been in.
I would absolutely do that again.
- Part of me is just like, I
would absolutely do that again.
And part of me is-
- Not anytime soon.
- Yeah, a part of me is just like,
man, I remember those
last six hours, that was-
- I'll do it again once
I forget about how hard
the last six hours were.
And I'm like, yeah, this is
fine, we can do this again.
- I mean, at least I had you
guys and Chris and Mouse there,
because, if I had done it by myself,
I would not have lasted 10 hours.
- No.
I remember the last two, three hours.
I was just running on complete autopilot.
You know when you're just
using the part of your brain
that isn't even thinking?
It's just like habits you've built up?
That was just me, I was just like-
- I saw bits and pieces of the board
where it's just you alone on the couch,
and you're just like, "Thank
you for the $20 donation."
(Garnt laughs)
- It kind of got to a point
where I was just
questioning my own insanity.
'Cause it was just-
- Is that sanity really?
- Sanity? Yeah.
- Or insanity?
I questioned my own sanity.
- Questioned my own sanity.
- My favorite clip though
is where you two were
on the couch and you just started going,
"Well, let's have all the boys.
All right, let's have all the boys."
And they Garnt, in the most
unenthusiastic way, goes,
"Get hype, guys."
It's like the most
not-hype "Get hype, guys"
I've ever heard.
- It just had such house party vibes.
It's just like when you stay up too late,
and there's that one guy
that just wouldn't leave.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that was exactly
what it felt like,
where I'm just like, I need to go to bed.
- Garnt is that one guy who doesn't leave.
- Yeah, you are, you are.
At every fucking all-night
karaoke, Garnt is the last guy.
- I mean, I was the last
guy in the stream as well.
I'm just like, you boys...
I mean, this wasn't the
competition obviously, obviously,
but I was the only one to
stay awake the entire time.
- I know, I know, I know.
- Right, right, right, right?
- If it was Connor that
was in your position,
he would've been like,
"Weak, you're all weak.
I won that competition."
- Absolutely.
- It was me.
I carried.
- I think, 'cause I knew
you guys were there,
and it was like, so I can sleep.
Then I was like, I will.
But I think if it was just
me alone, I would've had to,
I mean, I would have just ducked out.
- Oh yeah, of course, of course.
- And just been more miserable.
- I mean, the reason I didn't sleep
was because I knew as
soon as I closed my eyes,
they were not going...
I could not go to sleep and
come back up to stream again.
- I couldn't stop yawning.
- I just looked horrible.
I remember the last 30
minutes when I came back,
I looked half dead.
And I was like, oh god.
- I think I used all my
energy holding in the laughs.
I used an exceptional
amount of energy.
- I used so much energy
not saying anything during
the try-not-to-laugh segment.
That took a lot more energy
than I thought it did.
It actually took more
energy than doing the quiz,
talking, or just hanging out.
- Also not to mention that I
think we greatly overestimated
how much energy we were going to have,
because we had a schedule,
a preemptive schedule that staff made.
And we probably did maybe 40%
of what was originally scheduled.
- Yeah, I mean-
- 50.
- It was a few things,
'cause obviously Chris was
scheduled for two hours.
Stayed for six hours.
Which I'm not complaining,
I'm not complaining.
He was obviously having fun.
But then we also had a bunch of things
that we were meant to
be doing with Ironmouse.
But by the time Chris
left and Mouse came on,
it was just, we were so out of energy
that we were just like,
we can only manage talking right now.
- [Joey] Yeah, definitely.
- How did you guys manage
to recover afterwards?
Did you recover easily?
- I mean, recover is a strong word.
I went home, and weirdly enough,
I think because I was
kinda reliving the moment
when I was on the train ride home.
So by the time I got home, I
was wide awake for some reason.
And then I was doing a little bit of work
and then my body was just
like, I don't think so.
I literally passed out on my desk.
- Oh my god.
- For like an hour.
And I was just like, (sniffling).
Okay, I need to go to bed.
(all laugh)
And then I slept for
like 14 hours, I think.
- Oh my god.
- And then I just completely fucked
my sleep schedule for the next day.
- Yeah, I don't know.
My body's so weird after an all-nighter.
I hate it, I absolutely fucking hate it.
'Cause, during the stream, I'm
like, I'm going to pass out.
It's well documented how
close we were to passing out.
And so I remember, the stream finishes.
I do not even remember saying goodbye
to anyone in the office,
even though I know
we were all just like,
"Hey, congratulations!"
And they were like, "See you on Tuesday.
See you in like two days or whatever."
I think I said, "See you on Tuesday,"
but I think I just left as well.
I don't know if it seemed
like I was rude or something,
I need to go to my bed.
- You're so rude, Garnt. You're so rude.
- I remember like-
- Such a diva.
- I remember going to my
bed, being like, finally,
I've stayed up all night for this.
Didn't nap, didn't sleep.
I'm going to finally go to sleep.
Get on my bed, and my body's just like,
nope, you don't sleep now.
You stay awake.
You don't need sleep.
It is sunshine now.
- So how long did you stay awake till?
- I stay up for an extra...
It took me three hours to get
to a point where I could sleep
and then I slept for-
- So what?
It was like 3:00 PM, 4:00 PM?
- Yeah, that was around when I passed out.
- And I slept for two hours.
- Oh my god.
- So I was just, my day
was just fucked, I guess.
- When did you go to bed bed then?
- Like 2:00 in the morning.
- Oh my god.
- But then I did sleep for
like 16 hours, so that's-
- Wait, so you woke up at
like 4:00 PM the next day?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh my god, Garnt.
- That's why I woke up to
Connor streaming "Jump King,"
I was just like, fuck's sake.
How are these boys awake
and streaming right now?
I'm fighting for my life.
- On Sunday, I went home and
then I had three hours sleep.
And then I went out for
some drinks and a meal.
- How the fuck?
- I was fine.
- How?
- I got tired at around 10:00 PM.
So I went home and then I slept,
woke up early, and played "Jump King."
But I finished it.
- You finished it, yeah, congrats.
You've both finished it now.
- So did I.
- I finally finished
"Babe of the Ascension,"
which is the worst thing ever.
I don't ever wanna do it ever again.
- Finally finished the base
game, that was fun for-
- When you gonna do the DLC, Joey?
- You know what sucks?
At the end of that stream, I was like,
you can't pay me to play the DLC.
I want my happiness back in my life.
But then the moment I
turned off the stream,
I was like, fuck, I wanna keep playing.
- Yeah, because you're
like, but there's more.
- Yeah, because it was the fact
that there was so much
encouragement online
when I posted my time
and people were like,
"Dude, you're actually cracked."
And I was like, you know what?
Maybe I am.
- Give me a little more praise.
- Yeah, yeah, come on.
- Give me more praise.
- The game has a way of humbling you,
'cause I thought the same
thing when I did the third DLC,
I was like, I'm cracked, dude.
I'll be able to do this new one easily.
I was actually worried.
I was like, what if I
beat this DLC too fast?
- [Joey] Too fast.
- And it's like not a good stream arc.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then the first
eight hours of playing it,
I was like, oh no, oh no, this is hard.
This is really hard.
And it too me 48 hours-
- Damn.
- To beat the DLC.
- 48 hours.
- The fan-made DLC.
- But now I know what it feels
like to be an alpha gamer.
And now I can finally say,
hey, Garnt, when are you
finishing "Jump King," bro?
- Yeah, when are you gonna do "Jump King?"
- I'll do it, guys.
I fucking feel like fucking that scene
in fucking "My Hero Academia",
where like All Might is
just pointing at you saying,
"It's your turn now."
- It's your turn.
- Fuck's sake, All Might.
- You gotta do it, you gotta do it.
- I'm just here watching on TV.
I'm not even involved and
here you are pointing at me,
being like, "It's your turn."
- You've done half of it, so
you have to do the other half.
- Is it half of it? Is it half of it?
- No, Garnt got to maybe 40%.
- Yeah, I got 40%.
- Where did you get to?
- I can't remember.
- He got to the fucking-
- [Connor] The poles?
- No, not even there.
Before that, the town in the sky.
- Bargainburg.
- Bargainburg, that's it,
he got to Bargainburg.
- I mean, I will finish it,
just because I knew it's one
thing, when I started it,
and I was just like it's...
I have the same inkling feeling in me
where it doesn't feel
comfortable until I finish it.
- Taking your time, aren't you, Garnt?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's been a few weeks
since your last one.
You're gonna get rusty.
You'll start from zero again.
- I'll be fine, I'll be fine.
It'll be like pure muscle memory.
- It'd be like you never left.
- It's gonna be like
dementia the game with Garnt.
Every time he goes back to it,
he's like, oh, I gotta
learn this section again.
- It'll be like 30...
My playthrough will be
like 50 hours or something
spread between an entire year.
- Look, if anything,
you now have someone else
to compare yourself to.
And that's Meilyne, because
she also started it as well.
- Oh my god.
- That stream last night was hilarious.
- I saw Mudan started it as well.
- Yeah, Mudan started it.
- Jesus Christ, it's like a virus.
- But don't worry, if you thought...
Look, Meilyne just got to
the bottom of the sewers,
and it took her a couple
of hours to get there.
- I just think it's one of
the best games to stream.
It's so intuitive.
There's no explanation needed.
You know, some games there's
like power-ups, level ups.
And then there's like, oh,
you can unlock this thing,
and then everyone's like,
oh, what's going on?
But "Jump King" is literally just-
- One mechanic.
- You can see.
- You jump, one button.
- You understand immediately from watching
that they're trying to go
up, and when they fall,
you're like, oh, I get
it, this is fun to watch.
- It's also just a pretty game.
- It's good, right?
- It's a really pretty game.
- Yeah, I love the aesthetic.
I will say, I thought you were
bullshitting when you said,
"Oh, it's a fun game, it's a fun game."
But no, it is.
I do actually genuinely
think it's a fun game.
There's a high that you get when you reach
your new personal best.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
You're like, damn.
(Joey panting)
This is a good feeling.
And then that lasts for like three seconds
before you fall for the first time.
You're like, aw.
- I know we've spoke
on "Jump King" so much
on this podcast now, 'cause
it's like taken over my life,
but on the first map, there's
a very solid checkpoint.
When you get to that, you
feel like, I can do this.
- The 70% one, right? Yeah.
- Yeah, when you get to the-
- The church?
- The church.
- Yeah.
- And then you're like,
oh my god, I can do this.
- Yeah.
- That's when it feels good.
- That's when I was like,
all right, I got this.
You got this, king.
- Yeah, yeah, you can do it then.
If you can get there,
you can do it easily.
- So DLC for me is a hard maybe.
- No, you should do it.
- I think I want to maybe put
in a couple of other games
that I've been wanting to play.
- Hard maybe.
What does that even mean?
- It's a hard maybe.
- What were you, being like-
- Joey won't ever commit to anything.
So maybe is about the
best you'll get from Joey.
I mean, it's better than "Arcania,"
where he just will flat out say no.
- [Garnt] A hard maybe. (laughs)
- A hard maybe is like a-
- I am committed to my neutrality here.
It could be yes, it could be no.
- Do you want to marry the bride?
Do you wanna marry the bride?
- I am firmly planted.
- Maybe.
- That's a hard maybe, dog.
- That's a hard maybe.
- My ass is firmly planted on the fence.
- Was your viewership higher than normal
when you were doing "Jump King?"
- Oh yeah, yeah, for sure, for sure.
But you know, it's like,
what do I prioritize,
clout or happiness?
It's a hard choice for every YouTuber.
- You can have both.
- I'm just waiting for when
the Kirby game comes out, dude.
That's when real happiness comes out.
- I play games now, when
I play "Pokemon: Arceus,"
there's just not enough challenge.
Even though there was,
there literally was.
- There definitely was.
- But the thing was is
that I never once thought,
for a moment, I wasn't
gonna be able to do it.
Whereas "Jump King" has
that thing where it's like,
I don't know if you can do it, man.
- Wait, but you did
that last fight, right?
- The Volo, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, and you
struggled a lot with that.
- I did, but, at no point,
did I ever feel like,
this is too hard.
- Yeah, because to me, that was easily
the hardest in-game Pokemon fight ever.
- It is, it is, it is, but even then,
there's no point, when I'm doing it,
where I'm like, I don't
know if I can do this, man.
I just felt like I just gotta
grind a little bit more.
- I've gotta admit,
Arceus was hard as fuck.
- Okay, yeah, that one.
- I wanna see you do that.
- Whereas New Babe+, when
I was playing that game
of "Jump King," it's the second map,
I did it over three streams.
One stream, second stream, third stream.
The second stream after it and
I went to bed, I had anxiety.
I was like, what if I just can't do it?
- [Joey] Just can't do it.
- What if I can't do it?
I'm never gonna be able to
forget this if I can't do it.
And then I woke up the next
day and just bossed it,
just destroyed it in one hour.
- [Joey] Damn.
- I think you have an addiction.
- I do, yeah.
- [Joey] There's definitely
an addiction, yeah.
- I kind of got out of multiplayer games.
That was kinda where I got the kick from,
beating other people.
There's a hard ceiling
in multiplayer games,
where you're like,
if I wanna be able to
to improve at this game,
I have to put an absurd amount
of hours in consistently.
- Wait, but is 45 hours
in one "Jump King" map
not an absurd amount of time?
- Here's the thing, right?
- What is a lot of time?
- You could finish 13
Sentinels in that time.
- Think about it.
An FPS first-person shooter
multiplayer game, whatever,
45 hours is nothing.
- That's true.
- That's absolutely nothing.
- You're competing against
people who do 45 hours a week.
- Yeah, that's true.
- How many hours have you put into all
of "Jump King" right now?
- 100-something.
- That's quite a lot.
That's a "Persona" playthrough.
- That's a "Persona" playthrough.
- In "Apex," I have over 1,000 probably.
- Yeah, that's true.
- That's true.
- And even then, I got to master once,
and that was me going insane grinding it.
- Well, why don't you get
in some more challenging games then?
'Cause you said you don't really play
the "Souls" types games
or that kinda genre.
- I'm gonna do "Elden Ring."
- I feel like it's a
different type of challenge,
because, with "Jump King,"
it's just one mechanic
that you have to hone-
- Master.
- And master, whereas,
with something like
"Elden Ring" or "Sifu,"
it's a lot of things going on at once.
There's a lot of different approaches,
a lot of ways to master the game.
- Yeah, I just like "Jump King,"
'cause there's no bullshit.
If you fucked up, absolutely nothing,
there's no other single factor.
- Yeah, because with games
like "Dark Souls" or "Sifu"-
- [Connor] There's some
bullshit that can happen.
- It's like, you can
blame it on the enemy.
- What the fuck? That one frame hit me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I know I'll make up excuses.
- But in "Jump King," there's
no enemies to get in your way.
It's just you. You're
in the way of yourself.
- You are your own enemy.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Almost like fucking-
- Don't trust anyone, not even yourself.
That is "Jump King."
- Each DLC gets more brutal though.
The first "Jump King," you
can only fall two screens max.
- That's what I'm dreading, man.
- And I fell 20 in the latest one.
- What if I actually start raging?
- I do.
- I don't want that though.
I don't wanna get angry.
- Not like an actual angry though,
like an angry video-game angry.
You know what I mean?
It's a different kinda anger.
I don't know how to explain it.
It's an anger where you're like,
you shout, but it doesn't
actually get you upset.
You're just kinda like, (screams).
All right, back to it.
(Joey laughs)
- It's just like a slight
frustration, slight annoyance.
- Like stubbing your toe.
- Well, no, there's different
kinds of video game...
I don't know what that analogy was.
I'm not angry when I stub my toe.
- Not like a 13-year-old
on Xbox Live angry
where I just test out all the
new bad words I've learned,
not that kinda anger.
Just from out of frustration,
like when the website, when
you fill out the whole form,
and then it reloads for some reason.
You're like, (screams).
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, okay.
- Really? That's the anger you feel?
- Dude, when you enter a...
Have you not had that?
I get so angry when that happens.
You've filled out a whole signup form,
put the credit card
info in, the address in,
all in the right space.
You're about to go to the checkout.
For some reason-
- [Joey] It times out.
- Yeah, it times out, or it reloads.
Fucking Guts' theme goes through my head.
I'm like, is it even
worth signing up again?
I don't know if this is worth it anymore.
I don't even want the trampoline.
- The worst part is when you
fill out everything correctly
except for that one field,
but the website's designed in a way
that when you press send, it goes,
this one field is incorrect.
- We've reset the whole thing.
- But they've reset the
entire fucking thing-
- Yeah, dude.
- Yeah.
- That's the level of anger.
- Except for that one field.
- Oh, I hate that.
- Imagine that happens,
but it happens to every
website you sign up for.
- There's so many Japanese
websites like that as well.
- Every Japanese website, dude.
I don't know if Japanese people
are aware of UX designers,
but they certainly need some more.
- The amount of times
I've been fucking cucked
by not using half-width Katakana.
My fucking god, Jesus Christ.
- This is the biggest joke in Japan.
It's something you'll never experience
unless you either try to buy
stuff in on a Japanese website,
but, for some reason, they have full-width
and half-width Katakana and Hiragana.
- Can you explain that by the way?
What is the point of full
width and half width?
- I'll tell you exactly the difference.
There is none.
That's what's so frustrating about it.
- Someone explained it to me one time.
It had something to do with
how they coded way back,
the initial internet.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Here in Japan.
And it was a layover of that essentially
that they just kept using.
- Probably.
- And they never decided to sort out.
- Yeah, I mean, I've told the story
of how I interned for an IT company here,
and I got to fix a bunch
of clients' websites.
And I had to go through the HTML,
and I almost had a stroke
looking at some of these codes,
'cause it's like, oh my god,
you said you built this website last year.
You're using code literally from the '90s.
I was like, what?
Of course this page
takes 20 seconds to load
even though it's just text based,
because there's so much
bullshit code here.
- It's so weird-
- It's the worst.
- 'Cause it's almost like convenient stuff
and crazy stuff you can do
that you can't do in other countries.
- Yeah.
- And then they're like,
how about websites?
We just keep them shit.
- Weirdly enough, the
best designed websites
are the fucking anime trailer websites.
Yeah, the ones that are like,
they use fucking pretty Java and CSS.
It's like, oh, that looks fancy as fuck.
- Yeah, when that website
of when the last "Bakemonogatari"
volume was coming out.
And it was just scrolling down
for the entire history of the series,
I was like, damn, this is
beautiful-looking website.
- Oh my god, an actual coder,
an actual programmer made this, dude.
- Why can you not add
this to your UI design
when I'm trying to fucking buy something?
- Exactly.
- Or sign up to a site?
- Rakuten is just a hellhole of a website,
because you don't know, you go to...
'Cause on Amazon, for example-
- You see why Amazon's so good.
They don't do this shit.
- Because on Amazon, it's like, okay,
there's the fucking picture
of the thing you wanna buy.
There's how many is left,
when it's gonna arrive.
Here's all the information.
Everything is perfectly laid
out with every single item.
Meanwhile, with Rakuten, it's
just a fucking free for all.
It's like, would you like 17
banners that have nothing to do
with the product you're actually buying?
By the way, where is the purchase button?
Oh, it's buried deep beneath
this fucking wall of text.
And every time I go onto
Rakuten, it's so handy,
because you get so much stuff on Rakuten
that you can't get on Amazon,
but it's just a struggle
to try and buy anything,
because it doesn't even
tell you when it arrives.
- Oh, no, that's not the final boss.
The final boss is Yahoo! Auctions.
- Oh, yeah, Yahoo! Auctions.
(Joey groans)
- Where you can't even sign up
with an account that you want.
You need a special Yahoo! account.
So you need to just sign up to Yahoo!
It's not your normal Yahoo!
It's Japanese Yahoo! as well.
- So I have a Yahoo! email account,
some Duncan or something.
I don't know, they chose the name for me.
It's really weird.
- Of course it's a Yahoo! Japan account,
because no one outside of Japan
uses fucking Yahoo! anymore.
- Exactly, right, exactly.
So you just need to just sign up
with a special Yahoo! account
to sign up to this Yahoo! Auctions account
to then just not even,
I don't even know what the etiquette is
in terms of bidding stuff
and how to buy stuff.
- Dude, I dead ass never
even used Yahoo! Auctions
just because I refuse to
make a Yahoo! Japan account.
- I have a bad rating on it,
'cause I forgot one time
to say I got the thing.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got that on Mercari as well.
- I got a really angry message
from a dude who was like,
"Why haven't you told me that you got it?
This has been an awful experience for me."
I'm like, I just figured
if I didn't say anything,
that means I got it.
- Right, you'd think so.
- But how'd you pay?
Can you pay with credit card or something?
- Yeah, so it's really confusing.
When you auto-translate it
in Google, there's online pay
and something else that
sounds like online pay.
And I remember that I was confused,
and I clicked one of them.
And then I had to do this
whole weird kind of thing
with my bank where I had
to then contact my bank
to do the online payment.
- [Joey] Oh my god.
- Where there was just another field
that just let you put your
credit card information in.
It isn't clear, 'cause it
didn't say credit card.
It said something else.
Really annoying, really, really annoying.
I hate using it.
I just don't bother.
That's why I mean, as well,
a lot of the websites that
offer English, they're like,
okay, you click English, send
you to a brand new website
that doesn't have half the
shit of the Japanese one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Whereas Amazon, it's
like, you change to English,
nothing changes except the language.
- Yeah.
- It's great.
- It's exactly like when you
go to a Chinese restaurant
with your one Chinese mate,
and they're like, bring
on the special food.
- Bring on the real menu.
- Real menu.
- I don't know why it's Chinese
restaurants in particular,
but it seems like every
Chinese restaurant has
the special menu that you can only get
by asking in Cantonese
or Mandarin or whatever.
- And I bet they're not even
saying bring out the real menu.
It's probably just like
a codeword, you know?
It's like, mandarin is an orange.
And they're like, he said the word.
All right, bring it out.
- It just plays with my mind,
'cause I go to a Thai restaurant,
and I can ask them in Thai
whether they have a Thai dish
that they only do in Thailand
or only most Thai people would know.
Why is it that Chinese
restaurants just have
an unspoken understanding
that there's gonna be
so many people asking
for a special menu that they're
gonna make a special menu
in every single Chinese restaurant?
- Why are they literally gatekeeping?
It's like they're literally gatekeeping,
being like, if you're not Chinese,
you can't get the real shit, you know?
- It makes me feel sad though,
'cause I love Chinese food.
I never wanna go to a Chinese restaurant
without a Chinese friend.
- Yeah, I know, right?
- Yeah, I know, it sucks.
- 'Cause it feels like you
just unlocked the starter,
the starter kit, right?
And you need to learn Mandarin
to get the actual good gear.
Do you know what I mean?
'Cause I love Chinese food,
but the best Chinese food I've had
has not come from the normal menu.
If I go to a Chinese restaurant,
and I see fucking orange chicken,
sweet and sour chicken,
fried rice, all this stuff,
I was like, no, no, give me the real shit.
- Yeah, come on.
- Please give me the real shit.
I don't know how to access it.
- Where is your Chinese friend, huh?
- I do not know how to access it.
- I don't see him.
- Just speak Chinese for it.
Just speak Mandarin.
- Exactly.
- It's easy, it's easy.
Could you imagine if McDonald's did that?
It's like, oh, where is
your American friend?
- Wait, I know Shake Shack does though.
- Do they?
- Yeah, they have secret items.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I didn't know that.
- You didn't know this?
No, it's not Shake Shack, sorry.
In-N-Out.
- In-N-Out.
- Oh, In-N-Out.
Oh, I don't go to
In-N-Out, so that's fine.
- What possible special
menu could they provide?
- You can get the...
Well, I don't know,
it's animal style fries.
That's a secret menu item.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, I know that.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then there's a-
- Is that a secret menu though?
I feel that's so well known now.
- Yeah, but if you're a tourist from Asia
who doesn't speak English-
- [Joey] Oh, that's true.
- And you're like, what's that guy got?
What the fuck? How do I get that?
No one told-
- I'll never tell.
- I don't know.
I know you can get a flavor
where they mix all the
milkshake flavors into one,
which sounds interesting.
- It sounds interesting, yeah.
- I don't know if you want that.
I think there's something else.
There's another secret
burger or something as well.
I know there are secret
items at fast food chains.
- There are secret items.
- Items on the menu.
- Where would there be secret-
- Not like an entire-
- I don't know that-
- Because they're a
pain in the ass to make,
but if someone asks for it-
- Is it a marketing thing, you reckon?
- Also that as well, yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It makes you seem like you're-
- In the club.
- In a club.
- Part of the secret society.
I got the real stuff.
Give me the real stuff.
- Have you ever been to those places
that are secret bars or clubs or anything?
- Oh, like the invite-only ones?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You ever been to those?
- Yeah, one of my friends took
me to one where it literally,
it's in Tokyo.
I'm obviously not gonna say
where, but it literally-
- I'll never tell.
- I've been there.
- It literally looks like a concrete wall.
I was with my friend, and
he's like, "Okay, we're here."
And I'm like, "What do you mean?"
- Where is this?
- It's in Roppongi somewhere, I think?
- 'Cause we went to one in Shibuya, right?
- Yeah, that speakeasy.
- It said closed, and it
was closed due to corona.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Someone knocked on the
door, and they came out.
- [Joey] Oh, no.
- It wasn't even it looked closed.
It was just scaffolding,
and a wooden door.
- Oh, shit.
- Like the place was being
built and boarded off.
And you just knock on the door.
And like an actual speakeasy,
the fucking thing opens up.
- Yeah, my one had that
as well, so he knocked.
He's like, "Oh, I have to
knock a specific way as well."
I'm like, "Bullshit you do."
And he did a secret pattern.
And then the thing came up.
And he was like, "Password."
(speaking in foreign language)
And then he said the password.
And he was like, "Friend?"
He pointed at me, and he's
like, "Yeah, yeah, friend."
It was like, okay.
And then he opens it up.
And it's just this tiny
maybe three-person bar.
- [Connor] Right.
- It was all right, I guess.
- It was all right.
- It was cool that I was in there.
- The coolest part was just going
to what looked like a secret bar.
- The coolest part was
just the dude opening
it up like this.
I've only ever seen that in movies.
- I went to one where, it was in London.
I went to it, and it was
a breakfast restaurant
or something on the top.
We went in there.
And I didn't know the password,
and neither did my friend.
And then we were like,
"We don't know what the password is."
And he was like, "It's
a Daft Punk song lyric."
(Joey and Garnt laugh)
And he was feeding it-
- He was giving clues!
- He was feeding it to
me, and I was like...
It was something like,
I'm up all night to
get lucky or something.
- Right.
- Oh, okay.
- So he said it, then he was like-
- It's not even an obscure Daft Punk song.
- Oh, no, no, no.
- You just go through
their entire discography.
- [Joey] Yeah, which album?
- Which album are we talking about?
Okay, okay, can't be too many lyrics.
If it's Daft Punk lyrics,
that narrows it down.
- Is it "Around the World?"
- So then we're here,
and then some guy comes and greets us,
and we start walking through
this restaurant that's closed.
And then, like in a movie,
we go in the kitchen.
And there's people
working into the kitchen.
We're just walking through
their working in the kitchen.
- Oh, shit.
- And we go down into a
basement in the kitchen.
And there's boxes of fries
and shit all around us,
and we're going in.
Like in a fucking spy movie,
it's got the fucking beads.
- Oh, shit!
- For the door.
And it opens it up.
There's this room, I mean, it's fine.
- [Joey] Like a dimly lit room?
- It's okay, but there's
no real chairs or anything.
It's kinda like a very small
room that's very dimly lit.
It wasn't that good, and
the drinks were okay.
The coolest part was
walking to this thing.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then I was like,
now I wanna leave.
- Yeah.
- I've always wanted to know.
Why would you opt to make
a business like that?
- Novelty.
- I feel clearly if you're
going to opt to be like,
okay, I'm gonna make this so exclusive
that it's near impossible
for a regular person to find.
Then it's like you're clearly not doing it
as a sustainable business.
You're clearly just doing it
as a fucking hobby or something.
- The assumption is
you'll be able to survive
on word of mouth, I guess.
That's the hope.
- A lot of people are like,
"It's so cool, you gotta go."
And then the drinks are very mediocre.
But the experience feels worth it,
'cause you feel exclusive.
- Yeah, but it's just
bragging rights, right?
- Yeah, you pay for the experience
and not so much the bar or the business
or the drinks itself.
- It's like bars that are membership only.
And you can only get membership
by having someone recommend you.
That always seemed really silly to me.
But there's so many of them in Tokyo.
- That's like half of the
Golden Guy membership.
- Yeah, half of Nichome, as
well, is like that as well,
where it's like, if you don't someone
who either works there or
goes there frequently enough,
they just won't let you in.
- Yeah, but at the same time,
I get it with the bars in Golden Guy,
because the bars are so small
that I'm sure that their regular customers
can keep their business
up and running anyway.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's true.
- You just need one or two patrons.
So you get yourself going,
and then you're basically set.
- That's true.
- You're basically set.
- It'd be really cool to own
a tiny little bar in Golden Guy.
I've always thought about that.
- How hard is it to get a bar there?
- Yeah, that's what I've always wondered.
All those bars, even
though they're so tiny,
I'm sure they're paying out
the ass to have that space.
- We should put a Trash Taste bar there.
- A Trash Taste bar in Golden Guy?
- A Trash Taste special, build a bar.
- Build a bar in Golden Guy.
All three of us build our
own bars in Golden Guy,
see who makes the most money
at the end of the night.
- I don't even wanna do it.
- I don't even wanna think-
- A logistical nightmare.
- I don't even wanna think
about how much it must cost
to rent out a space there.
- I'd get really claustrophobic
working one of those bars.
- No, it's cozy.
- You think it's cozy?
- Yeah, I think it's cozy.
- It depends.
I've been in some where it's like,
I literally can't stand up
straight inside of them.
- It's literally a shoebox.
- Yeah, it is.
- And I don't even know
how they get into the bar
let alone work behind the bar.
- Well, most of them are four feet tall
like (speaking in
foreign language), right?
- That's true, that's true.
- They probably don't have any problems.
- It's not built for
someone of my stature.
If I stand up, my head
literally hits the ceilings.
- I feel like Gandalf in Frodo's house
in a lot of these places, all right?
I'm just constantly, can
I get a drink please?
- It's normally if you're wide
that's the problem though,
not if you're tall.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's true.
- But that's why going in
the wintertime is the worst,
because you're all puffed
up with jackets and shit.
You're just like, all right,
out of the way please.
Sorry, excuse me.
- I think it's best to
go at winter though.
In the summer, it feels weird.
I don't know why.
- I feel, in the summer, it's way too hot.
- It's hot, it's really hot.
- Yeah.
- Even when the AC's
going, it's still there.
- Either way, it's very much a gamble.
I've heard so many horror
stories in Golden Guy
and Nichome and all that stuff.
- Just don't go into a bar
if someone tells you to go into a bar.
That's the rule of thumb.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- If somebody is trying to
tell you to go into their bar,
that's a good sign to
not go into that bar.
- Probably a bad idea.
- Gentlemen, this episode of Trash Taste
is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
Going online without ExpressVPN
is like using your
smartphone without a case.
It's barbaric.
Most of the time, you'll be fine,
but all it takes is one incident
for you to wish that you used a case.
Every time you connect to an
unencrypted network in cafes,
hotels, airports, et cetera,
your online data is not secured.
Any hacker on the network can gain access
and steal your personal data,
passwords, financial details, and more.
It doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack someone,
just some cheap hardware.
So why use ExpressVPN?
Well, it creates a secure
and encrypted tunnel
between you and the internet.
So hackers won't be able to
find out what you're doing.
And it's super secure.
It would take a hacker
over a billion years
to get past ExpressVPN's encryption.
And me and the boys have
been using ExpressVPN
for a goddamn hot minute.
It's just so easy.
It's so easy.
You just click the button, and it works!
So secure your online data today
by going to expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
That's E-X-P-R-E-S-S-V-P-N.com/trashtaste,
and you get an extra three months free.
Expressvpn.com/trashtaste,
link in the description.
Back to the episode.
- Yeah, I've only been
to Golden Guy two times.
I haven't been that many times.
And it's been a interesting
experience every time.
- Yeah, the last time I went
was with you guys at that bar.
- I think that was fun.
- Yeah, which was really, really fun.
- That was a good time.
- Yeah.
- When was that?
- That's the one that Jan came to.
- Oh, that one, yeah, yeah.
- And he immediately went behind the bar
and starts serving drinks.
- He just took over the bar.
- He just took over, yeah!
- Was it 'cause the
woman who was at the bar
got tired or something?
- Yeah, it was owned by this,
what looked like a, at least,
70, 80-year-old old lady.
She was really, really nice,
but she was clearly standing
at the bar all night.
And the moment Jan came in, she was like,
oh, that looks a charismatic enough guy
to take over my bar for the night.
She literally ushers Jan over,
because there were no seats left.
'Cause there was us three and
two other Japanese people,
and that was it.
It was so small.
So Jan comes in, he's like,
"I got nowhere to sit."
Old lady just ushers Jan over
and is like, "Take over."
And then she just goes behind the back.
And we never see her for
the rest of the night.
And I'm just like, we can
just leave if we wanted to.
Obviously, we paid at the end of it.
- It was like 1,000 yen a drink,
but it was like you
were pouring the drinks.
It was like you could just make
it as strong as you wanted.
- Exactly.
- It was really strange.
It was a really fun time though.
- It became a self-service bar,
and I don't know how Jan has this effect
basically everywhere he goes
where he just sweet talks
the fucking restaurant,
the waiter, or the bar lady
to give us the special service
or the special menu,
the menu that doesn't exist, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's always someone like
Jan who is able to to get-
- Jan is the only man
that can somehow pull out
a secret menu from a restaurant
that doesn't even have a secret menu.
It's just like, oh, I guess we
have a secret menu now, fuck.
All right, bring it out for this guy.
- Can you imagine going to a
British restaurant or something
and be like, you gotta
get out the secret menu,
and it's just toast sandwich.
- Unfortunately.
- Toast sandwich, crisp sandwich.
- Unfortunately, I think
the UK is the one place
where sweet talking doesn't do anything.
They just tell us no.
- Really?
- No.
I've never seen anyone sweet
talk anything in the UK.
Maybe in a bar with one guy,
but in a restaurant, it'll never work.
- Or maybe it's because
they just don't have
secret menu culture maybe?
- No, we don't.
- What would be on the
Japanese secret menu?
If you went an abroad-
- Something slimy.
- Natto, natto?
- Cognac or something.
- I don't know, I feel like we don't have
secret menus here either,
just because we don't even
have tipping culture here.
Because we're just so
like, these are the rules.
We can't make any kind of exceptions.
- Why would you wanna hide
something if you're proud of it?
- Right.
- What I'm talking about is,
if you go to a Japanese
restaurant not in Japan-
- Oh, I see.
- What would be the foods on there
that would be something that you,
a Japanese person very accustomed
to Japanese cuisine would know,
but is, I guess, not
mainstream enough to be-
- So you're asking what the most
underrated Japanese food is?
Or unknown Japanese foods.
- I would say it'd
probably be something slimy
like most of the shit that
we've ended up feeling
in the What's In The Box
on the charity stream.
- Like mozoku or natto.
- Yeah, yeah, shit like that.
- Like okra, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Probably, something like that.
Maybe like, I don't know,
natto in curry maybe.
- 'Cause I feel like
a lot of izakaya foods
would be on there.
- Oh, yeah, definitely.
Yeah, like the blended squid
and stuff like that, or takowasa.
That shit's bomb.
- Oh, no way, no way.
- Hey, man, you're part of my team now,
because you like natto.
- Okay, natto was actually all right.
It was all right.
- The taste is fine, but
the slime is just dreadful.
- Yeah?
- Really vile.
- The slime, it's not
even the worst texture
I've had in Japan, I feel like.
It looks a lot of worse than it tastes
and feels in your mouth, I think.
I think the beans taste pretty good.
I mean, it just tastes
like soy sauce, I think.
I mean, it smells-
- That's basically what it is.
- I mean, that's what it is.
- It's just soy sauce on soy beans.
- Yeah, yeah, right?
- It's just like soy overload.
- Right, right.
- I feel though, because you guys ate it
straight out of the packet,
you got the full brunt of the
sliminess and the texture,
but when you put that on a bed of rice,
because you're eating it with rice,
it doesn't feel as slimy as it should've.
- I feel like, with a bit of
rice, it would be perfect.
It would be absolutely perfect.
- [Joey] It's fantastic.
- Yeah, I mean, I guess, you gotta open-
- [Joey] Just give it a go.
- Give it a go, give it a go sometimes.
- And if you don't like it,
it's totally fine, I understand.
- Maybe you like it, maybe you're not.
To me, I learned that I
just can't handle ketchup.
I don't know why, I don't know why.
That was a first-
- To be fair, that was a lot of ketchup.
- That was the first time...
- Garnt's referring to
the 24-hour livestream.
- To explain, we all had forfeits to do.
I had to eat pizza crusts drenched
in ketchup and mayonnaise,
because I hate ketchup and mayonnaise.
- And you don't eat the crust.
- And I don't eat the crust.
And I remember, I was like,
I'm gonna give this the best
go that I can possibly can,
because it's for charity.
And it's the first time where
I've put something in my mouth
and I had immediate gag reflex.
- That's 'cause it's your mind.
Your mind is telling you
that you don't want it.
- [Joey] Mind over matter.
- To me, like the natto, I was just like,
maybe I'm gonna gag during the natto.
And I had it, and I'm just like-
- It's 'cause you expected to gag.
I think you expected to throw up,
so you were psyching yourself out.
So the moment it touched
your tongue, you're like-
- Yeah, to be fair though,
that smell was pretty dreadful.
I had to do the ghost
pepper. That was dreadful.
- How was that experience?
- That hurt.
See, because you guys were saying, oh,
and everyone in the chat was saying,
oh, look forward to the next morning.
You're gonna be shitting through a straw.
And I was like, oh, god-
- No, no, the ramen was way worse.
- Yeah, the ramen was
way worse that we had.
Yeah, I was fine.
I had maybe one painful shit,
and then, I thought that was
gonna the beginning of the end.
- No, no, no, just one.
- No, no, no, no.
- The one that's spicy
is the only one you get.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But yeah, I was fine after that.
I look back on the clip of me shivering
for 15 minutes afterwards.
I literally look like
I'm about to fucking die.
- Yeah, I was getting slightly worried
when you started shivering,
but I know it's because your
body is just going into shock.
- [Joey] Yeah, pretty much.
- Your body is rushing
you of fucking adrenaline
and endorphins and all that kinda shit.
I just remember seeing you go like this,
and I'm just like, "Joey,
are you all right, man?"
- I think the worst part about it is,
when you watch that out of context,
you see a dude who looks
clearly sleep deprived
with huge bags under his eyes shivering.
I just looked like a crack addict.
I just looked like I
was having withdrawals.
I was sleepy just going like, (panting).
It was not the best look.
- I don't think the sleep
deprivation helped as well,
'cause I can't imagine trying
a food that you really-
- It was like seven in the morning.
- Yeah, it was seven in the morning.
We were up for like 20 hours
at that point, and you're like-
- It taste good?
- Perfect time,
perfect time to eat a ghost pepper.
- No.
To be honest, I couldn't taste anything.
- Oh.
- Yeah, there was no flavor.
- Was it as painful as
you thought it would be?
- Yeah.
- I find that sauces,
like really heavy sauce-based
dishes that are spicy,
are the hardest to eat.
Like the Hot Ones stuff,
I can eat all of those Hot Ones sauce,
like the hottest ones, on wings, no issue.
I don't need milk or anything like that.
It tastes good, like the Last Dab.
I slather everything in that.
It's all good, 'cause
it's just a few bites,
but it's very solid.
But we did the ramen video for yours.
And that wasn't that spicy.
I'd say it's not as
spicy as a ghost pepper
or a Carolina Reaper,
because it's just sauce.
It coats your mouth, coats your esophagus,
and it goes into your stomach.
It hurts so much.
And then it takes a while,
so you just keep eating and eating.
- Yeah, I definitely struggled more,
I think, with that than the ghost pepper.
- One burst of spice is not that bad.
It's when you keep eating bursts of spice
that the pain just multiplies.
- It builds up.
- You don't give yourself a break.
That's why eating one
Carolina Reaper, for me,
is totally chill.
I could do it now, and we
could still film the episode,
and it'd be chill.
Those competitions where they eat 40,
I'm like, that's fucked, that's fucked up.
- How has anyone not died from that?
- I don't know, 'cause-
- I don't know, I don't think-
- Can you die from spice?
- No, you can go into shock though.
- You can go into shock, but I don't...
Has there been a recorded case
of someone dying from spice?
I'm not sure if there is.
There has been?
- [Ashley] You can burn a
hole through your stomach.
- I don't necessarily think
that's true though, I think.
- You'd have to have a
pretty weak stomach though,
I feel, for that.
- Yeah.
- I think it's a factor of things.
- For me, as someone who loves spicy food,
trying to explain why I
eat spicy food or why...
Jerry's said to me all the time,
"Oh, I don't know how
you can get through that"
or something like that.
I think, one thing
that's really underrated
about why people eat spicy food
is that the spicy food needs
to taste good, you know?
When we think of spicy
challenges, we just think
about getting through how
spicy this spicy meal is,
or getting through this
fucking pepper or something.
A big draw of spicy food is that,
even if you're in fucking pain
and your mouth is hurting,
if it tastes good with the spice,
you wanna finish it, and you wanna eat it,
because it tastes good.
- I mean, that was it
with the ramen video.
I would not have finished that
if it didn't taste as good as it did,
and it tasted really fucking good.
If that did not taste good,
I would've just been like, no, fuck this.
- Yeah, I've had, for example,
the Coco Ichiban level 10 spice.
And it is spicy, but it
doesn't taste good at all.
It just feels like you're making
it spicy to make it spicy.
- Just artificial?
- It's just artificial.
Sometimes it just feels like,
this is just a flex at the end of the day,
where we can make it this
spicy, but it doesn't even,
the taste doesn't marry
well with the spice at all.
Proper good spicy dishes
need to taste good.
- It needs to complement
the actual base food.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
For example, I have Thai
food without the spice,
and it literally does feel
like there's a component
that's missing from the food.
- Yeah, fuck, so good.
- Yeah, what are you gonna say, Ashley?
- [Ashley] Capsaicin does
cause tissue inflammation,
so a large enough dose
could cause serious damage
to your stomach and intestines.
- I feel you'd have to have
an egregious amount though
to hit that point.
- [Ashley] Or something really spicy,
you'd have it all in one sitting,
you could do enough damage
to potentially kill you.
- My ex-girlfriend was Sri Lankan.
I remember when I went to
meet her parents and stuff,
everything had chilies in it.
- Of course, yeah.
- It was amazing. I loved it.
It was breakfast, omelet.
We had five of those peppers
that you put in Thai food.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Fucking hell.
- And I ate 'em all.
And then, I don't know
if I told this story,
but her mom came in and was like,
"Why did he eat the peppers?"
And I was like, "Am I not
supposed to eat the peppers?"
And she was like, "No,
you'll get stomach cancer
if you eat the peppers."
I'm like, "Why would you
put them in the food then?"
What the fuck?
They were delicious.
It was good.
- Yeah.
- There was also another restaurant,
'cause she took around to a
bunch of the local restaurants.
And there was one thing
were it was deviled mutton,
it was called, or something.
- That sounds badass.
- It was like the most
delicious marinated mutton
I'd ever had in my life.
- Damn.
- But it was like doom level of spice.
- Well, if it's got the word devil in it-
- Devil, yeah.
- Devil's blood.
- I'm tearing up, but I'm like,
fuck, it's so good. (whimpering)
Even though I was in so much pain,
I'm like, just another bite.
It's so good.
- That's the thing about spicy food.
If it's really good spicy food-
- You power through, you power through.
- Fuck me, just one more bite.
When you take the bite, you're in a pain,
but you're just like, oh,
it just tastes so good!
- I don't know how to explain it,
but when it's super spicy
and super delicious,
it's almost like it's
searing in the flavor
into your tongue.
- Right, right, right.
- So I'm like, this is
so much flavor! (screams)
- 'Cause it's almost like,
if you take the spice out,
for example, I've had unspiced Thai curry.
I've had unspiced Indian curry as well,
'cause we live in England.
- No, don't do that.
Come on now.
- The best way I can describe it
is that it just tastes flat.
It tastes flat.
There's something that's
missing from the taste.
- It's like uncarbonated soda.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, kinda.
That's a good analogy actually.
The flavor's there, but there's a texture
or something is missing.
- The flavor is there,
but the personality is gone.
- Exactly. (laughs)
- Indian curry, if you
have rice with it too,
or you have naan,
I feel like that's so nice
to have spice with it,
'cause then it kinda
helps mellow it out a bit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- That's true, that's true.
Yeah, see, 'cause I never,
for the longest time,
I didn't understand that
concept of spice enhancing food,
because up until, I'd say,
maybe three or four years ago,
I could not handle spice at all.
If I went to Coco Ichi,
I would do level one,
which is like the most basic shit.
And I'd just be like, "No,
too spicy, I can't do it."
And then, I don't know what it was that,
where just one day, I
kinda just flipped a dime.
And I was like, you know what?
It hurts, but I'm enjoying
it for some reason.
What is this?
- I had the opposite journey of Joey,
someone who's grown up with
Thai food and stuff like that.
I remember, when I was a kid,
I really did not like
Japanese food at all,
because a lot of Japanese cuisine revolves
around the natural flavor of stuff.
- [Joey] Savory.
- Savoring it and just bringing
out the natural flavors
of the ingredient.
And me, a Thai person, being like,
there is not enough
ingredients in this dish.
What, sushi?
Sushi, what, that's just-
- [Joey] Two ingredients.
- That's rice and fish.
Where's the spice? Where's the flavor?
- Wasabi.
- But yeah, three ingredients like rice.
You have rice with a bit of
vinegar in it, fish, and wasabi.
I'm just like, where's
the five million spices
to go with it?
What? You dip it in soy sauce?
Where's the chilies in the soy sauce?
- Where's the kick?
- Yeah, where's the kick?
Japanese cuisine was my
least favorite cuisine,
because to me, there just
weren't enough extra spices
or extra ingredients
to enhance the flavors.
- Is this unseasoned sushi?
(Garnt laughs)
- And then, as I grew
older, I'm just like,
as I grew older, I learned
to really appreciate
the subtleties in the
flavor of Japanese cuisine.
It really enhances the good ingredients.
- It's just rice, isn't it?
- It's just rice.
- It's all just the same.
Sushi chef straight up for 20 years
to get the perfect rice.
It's all rice, isn't it?
- It's all the same.
- What is this, Uncle Ben's?
What is this?
(all laugh)
- Did you put it through a colander?
- Is this microwaved?
- Did you wash this rice?
- Did you wash this
rice through a colander?
- It's microwave rice, right?
Five-minute rice?
- Minute Maid rice.
- I fucking love the golden rice
in those microwave packets though.
I fucking love that rice.
- Oh, the ready-to-make ones, right?
- Yeah, dude.
- Yeah.
- It tastes so good.
- [Joey] Yeah, they do taste good.
- Probably 'cause it has all
the artificial shit in it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Fast food rice.
How do we make rice
unhealthy, super unhealthy?
We found a way.
- Yeah, honestly, the fast
food, the packeted fried rice
that you can buy is actually pretty damn-
- In Japan, it's pretty good.
- The one that you buy in the freezer?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I used to live off it.
I was like, oh, well, I made
curry, and I don't wanna make,
I didn't have a rice cooker at the time.
And I hated making rice the
way that my mom taught me,
which is just boil a pan
full of water and guess.
Which sometimes works, sometimes didn't.
- But doing it in Japan is blasphemous.
- I know, I know, I know.
It's weird, 'cause you'd
think that the first people
to adapt an easier way to
do it would be white people,
'cause they love being lazy.
- [Joey] That's true.
- You'd think rice cookers would go down,
especially for the UK where we love rice.
We love eating it with
curry, so you'd think that-
- Do people in the UK love rice?
- With curry.
- That's pretty much it though.
- But that's the only
thing we eat half the time.
We eat chicken tikka masala,
it's like every week.
- [Joey] That's true, that's true.
- You'd think that we would figure out,
hey, these rice cookers aren't so bad.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'Cause I remember growing up in the UK,
whenever I'd have my
packed lunch of whatever,
it would be like something-
- No, you'd never make
rice for a packed lunch.
It's a dinner thing.
- Yeah, no, it's-
- No, sorry, tea, tea.
No, fuck, it is dinner.
- Supper?
- It is dinner.
- Supper.
- Whatever you wanna call it.
- Tea is a Northern thing.
- Sorry, sorry.
- Tea to me is the drink, you know?
- I could see that, tea.
I know, I know.
- As with most of the-
- I know, I know, I know.
- As with most of the developed world.
- Tea for me is a twit longer.
- Awful joke.
- Awful joke, I'm sorry.
- No, but I remember
having this conversation
with my mates, and they were like,
"Wait, you eat rice every
day with every meal?"
And I'm like, "Yeah, yeah,
you have it with every meal."
They couldn't wrap their
heads around it, I guess.
- You bougie motherfucker.
- You eat rice with everything?
You don't take a break
from rice? It's everything?
I'm like, yeah, it's Asian cuisine.
You literally eat rice with everything.
- I'm sure the Asians are
asking the same thing,
being like, wait, you use
bread with everything?
Every meal is with bread?
- It's bread or potatoes?
Is that it?
- Is that it?
- Bread and potatoes?
- Why not both?
(all laugh)
- Carbs on carbs.
- I mean, I think it's grown
a lot in popularity though
in the last 10 years especially.
- Rice?
- Yeah, definitely not when
I was growing up at all.
- It's become way more popular,
rice-based dishes in general.
- I say finally.
What took them so long?
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I think there's enough dishes
where people are making
them where a rice cooker...
People buy bread makers.
People aren't making
bread every fucking week.
And those things are fucking massive.
- [Joey] Yeah, right.
- My little rice cooker is this big.
But the point was, before I did this,
I used to just buy the microwave packets.
They're amazing.
300-gram packets, perfect
portion, tastes great.
Slap it on the plate, you're good to go.
Amazing, amazing.
- I actually think those,
I also survived without a rice cooker
in university for a long time,
'cause the microwave
packets were good enough.
The problem with a rice cooker,
I find, is that the rice
goes off so fucking quick.
So either you cook a tiny bit of rice
in this massive rice cooker,
because I'm Asian, and of course,
if a mom buys you a rice cooker,
it's like the biggest fucking rice cooker
you can ever imagine.
- How many families do you wanna feed?
- It's like those restaurants
ones where it's this big.
- Luckily, there was
a humanitarian crisis,
but it wasn't for long,
'cause Garnt had his rice
cooker that his mom gave him.
- Yeah, 'cause my mom bought me
a rice cooker for university,
'cause that's one of the
essential pieces of equipment
that you need for university
for every Asian kid
that their mom provides.
- [Joey] Of course.
- They provide you a rice cooker
that could survive a nuclear winter.
- I'm pretty sure you
could hop inside of it
and survive a blast, right?
- Yeah, right, right.
But the problem is, I would
always cook too much rice
or too little rice, right?
It would be either too much
for the meal I was cooking,
and I would have some leftover rice.
Or I would cook too much rice,
and the rice just goes off so quickly,
even if you put in the
fridge or something.
Because unless you're really,
and this is the Asian trap, right?
Because with the rice cooker,
you have to eat rice every day
in order to eat all the rice
that you cooked with the rice cooker.
Otherwise, it's just gonna go off.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- So that's why actually
the microwave packets
were just the perfect
portion for one meal,
and it was just a lot less effort.
- Yeah, because then you
have to start experimenting.
You look in your fridge
and be like, all right,
what can the rice go with
that I haven't tried yet?
- However can you dehydrate
the rice that you've cooked,
turn it back into a rice grain?
Is that possible?
- Well, I mean-
- Could you do that if
you had the technology?
I'm asking is it possible.
- Well, I mean, I've put a-
- Have you tried?
- [Ashley] No, it's like popcorn.
You don't turn back the popcorn to its-
- Oh, that form is
completely different though.
The rice stays the same.
I think if you took the water out somehow,
maybe we could do it.
Scientists, can we un-hydrate rice?
- My family, or actually a
lot of Japanese families,
what they do is, if
they make too much rice,
then you put it into small
maybe microwave-sized packets,
and then you put it in the freezer.
- Yes, that was also
what happened as well.
- But it's not the same.
The next morning, you wake up being like,
okay, there's some leftover rice.
If I don't eat it, my mom's
gonna fucking throw a hissy fit,
so let's just get it out.
Defrost that shit.
- But there was no space in my freezer
to put extra packets of frozen rice.
Do you know why?
As a university student,
what happens when your mom comes over?
She brings you eight Tupperware
boxes full of takeaway food.
And then you gotta put it in the freezer.
It lasts you the entire day.
- Oh, you're that asshole.
- No, the entire fucking term.
I was that asshole, I was that asshole.
- You're that asshole.
You know when you go to share a freezer,
and some fuck takes up
the entire fucking thing?
'Cause he decided that
he was gonna meal prep
an entire month?
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're a cunt, you know that?
We gotta share the freezer?
Where is my Ben and Jerry's gonna go?
- Where am I gonna put my vodka?
- I just wanted one Ben
and Jerry's in here.
Is that too much to ask?
- You start playing "Tetris"
with all the rice packets.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, 'cause my mom would come to visit me
once a month in university.
And every month, she'd
bring two full Sainsbury's-
- Oh my god.
- Bags worth of takeaway
boxes of food.
- Holy shit.
- And I'm just like, that is...
I don't know, I don't know.
- How many people were you
sharing one fridge with?
- Six or seven or something like that.
- So at best, you have
half a shelf to yourself.
And then you have one, a
freezer is even smaller.
- The freezer was smaller, yeah.
- So you had, what?
Two items to put in the freezer?
Garnt, you must've been hated.
They must've hated you.
- I probably was hated.
- They probably hated you.
I would throw a fit.
- I would've hated you.
- I'd be like, Garnt, mate,
either you're sharing this with me,
that's my real estate,
or I'm putting stuff in there, dude.
Now you gotta say bye bye.
- You're invading my
property a little bit.
Gonna have to pull the short gun on that.
- You're gonna have to
haggle with me here a bit.
We gotta figure something out.
- [Joey] Oh, god.
- What it's like living with
a Southeast Asian guy or girl.
- That's realizing it.
- Whenever their parents come
to visit, they just
bring a shit ton of food.
I don't know why it's part of our culture.
- I feel like that's just
like an Asian in general.
- Is it true with Japanese?
'Cause I know it's true with
Southeast Asian and Chinese-
- I know when I was living with,
I know when I was living on my own still,
my aunt used to come over
and just buy me a shit ton of food.
That was when I was house
sharing with two other people.
Yeah, I was also the asshole
that took up 80% of the freezer.
I knew very well-
- I can't believe I'm
cohosting with these assholes,
these barbarians, filling
up the fridge selfishly.
- [Joey] Hey, man.
- This is our turn to colonize.
We're colonizing one freezer at a time.
- How does it feel?
- Hey, I'm Welsh, dude.
I'm Welsh, bro, what the fuck?
(Garnt laughs)
- [Joey] How does it feel now?
- Welsh can't get a
break, man. Fuck, dude.
- [Joey] Oh, god.
- One freezer at a time.
We're coming for your freezers, okay?
- This episode is sponsored by Levoit.
- Lads, something smells a bit.
- What is this?
Why is there a PC and
dirty laundry on the table?
- Fear not, lads, for we
have the Levoit air purifier.
This video is brought to you by Levoit.
PC filled with dust and
having a hard time getting
these optimum frames for your game?
No worries.
Is your room filled with dirty laundry
and smells horrible?
Not a problem.
Perhaps you maybe got some cat litter
giving you some headaches?
Like Meilyne?
- That's just Meilyne.
That's just Meilyne.
- That's Meilyne.
Well, Levoit is the
perfect solution for you.
- Joey, isn't this the
sock that Levoit prepared
just for you?
- Oh, thank you.
- Oh no.
- [Garnt] Joey, what's in it?
Please tell me it's
not what I think it is.
- [Connor] What's in the sock?
- It's not cat poo.
- Oh my god.
- It's a letter.
- Meilyne didn't do anything! Thank god!
- Oh my god, the sock is telling me
that the GP lifespan and performance
can be cut by over 50%-
- Oh my god.
- Due to overheating
commonly caused by dust?
- Oh my god.
And if you want to get your very own,
make sure to click the link
in the description down below.
It helps Levoit know to sponsor us again.
And the stench is getting
purified as we speak, gentlemen.
So get yourself a Levoit air purifier
from the description link below.
- It smells clean.
- Back to the episode.
- Did your parents send you care packages
when you went to university?
- If I say no, they might say otherwise.
- It's like, how dare you don't remember.
- They might see this episode and be like,
"We sent you things, Connor."
I don't think they did.
I wanna say that, no, I don't think so.
I remember the last house
I moved into in university,
it was like, we moved
in, it was a bit beat up.
It wasn't great.
And my mom was mortified.
She was like, "Oh my god,
this place is a shithole.
Oh my god, you can't
be caught living here."
I'm like, "It's not that bad.
I'll get over it. I'll be fine."
I just remember her reaction.
She was just like,
I thought she was actually gonna be like,
"You can't, you can't, you
have to find somewhere else.
This is too old."
I was like, "No, it's fine."
It wasn't even that bad.
It was just kinda messy.
- Is this the one in Swansea?
- Yeah, that one was the
one that later had rats.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- But I don't think the rats were a part
of the initial moving-in thing.
They joined later.
They moved in with me.
- They were the other roommates.
- They weren't part of the package?
- No, I didn't preorder
those unfortunately.
Yeah, no, I mean, fuck.
I'm trying to think now.
I only ever had white roommates actually.
It sounds bad.
I guess, in Swansea, there
isn't much diversity.
There wasn't.
I did have some friends who
were from Chinese schools,
but most of them didn't speak-
- Like exchange students or?
- A lot of foreign
students come to the UK.
- Right, right, right.
- Yeah.
- The UK has a lot of
foreign students in all.
- That makes sense.
- I mean, there's a ton of universities.
I think, every city has two.
- Yeah, you guys have some of the highest
universities as well, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- A lot of people come for that.
- A lot of prestigious ones as well.
Not Swansea, but maybe
another prestigious one.
Maybe Oxford was full.
I had some friends that were Chinese,
but they didn't speak much English.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- There was such a, I
can't remember his name.
I had did some projects
with him in first year,
and he didn't know what
the fuck was going on.
We kinda just helped.
We were like, "We'll just
help you. We'll just do it."
He was like, "Thank you, thank you.
I'll return the favor."
And then, he never returned-
- We never saw him again.
- He never returned the favor.
- Never saw him again, right?
And then, two years
later, same engineering.
I'm like, oh my god, I saw him again.
I was like, "How you doing, man?"
And his English was quite
a bit better this time.
He spoke a bit more English.
Still wasn't great,
but it was pretty good.
And he was really
struggling with this thing.
And we had a spare slot in
our group, and we were like,
"Just join us, 'cause we're
basically nearly done.
And you'll get a passing grade."
And he was like, "Oh, shit, no way."
We were like, "What do you do for fun?"
He's like, "I'll show you."
Dead ass, we're in the computer libraries
just working on this thing,
and this is when we
invited him to join us.
We're just talking, 'cause
he was sitting with us.
And we're like, "Oh,
yeah, what do you do?"
He's like, "I'll show you, show you."
So he takes us outside.
He just starts breakdancing.
- Hell yeah.
- Insane.
- Fuck yeah!
- Insane, 'cause he didn't
wanna explain it or something.
I can't remember what it was.
He just starts doing
insane flips and shit.
We're computer nerds and engineers.
And we're just like, what?
What is this?
- That's fucking awesome.
- It was so bizarre.
- The glow-up, dude.
- Yeah.
- And then he was like,
"Yeah, I love breakdancing.
It's my passion and stuff."
And I was like, "Nice, dude, nice."
I was like, "What are
you gonna do after this?"
He's like, "I don't fucking know."
He's like, "I'm just here
until my parents drag me back."
And I was like, "I don't
know, fair enough."
- Breakdance my way to a degree.
- And so, he was like, "By
the way, I didn't forget.
I wanna return the favor for
you guys helping me so much."
- [Joey] Oh, yeah?
- I didn't see him for a long time.
And then one day I was on
the bus back to my house,
and he was there, he was like,
"Dude, let me return the favor for you."
And I was like, "Oh, okay, sure, sure."
And so we go into town.
He's like, "Look, my friend
owns this boba store."
I'm like, of course.
I'm like, yeah, I don't wanna
be racist, but it makes sense.
- It made sense, yeah.
- It makes sense, yeah.
- Your Chinese friends own the boba store.
- Yeah, of course.
It makes sense, it makes sense.
- My first time ever having boba.
And he's like, "Yeah, you gotta
try this. This is amazing."
- Oh, really?
- He said, "You love tea?"
I'm like, "Yeah, I love tea, I love tea."
I'd never heard of boba before.
This is like 20-
- Is this before it exploded, right?
- Yeah, this is 2015.
- Before the boba explosion.
- And I've never even seen this stuff.
And they were putting these,
what I thought were, balls into my drink,
tapioca at the time.
He puts 'em in, I'm
like, "I don't know, man.
This isn't like tea I've had before.
And it's cold?"
- Yeah.
- Oh, I don't know about that.
So I have this, and he makes it for me.
He's like, "It's free of
charge, free of charge."
I'm like, okay, okay, okay.
I'm like, all right, I'll give you,
I don't know how much
this work would've cost
if I charged you, but all right.
- Free boba.
- I was very grateful.
And I drink it.
And immediately, I'm like (coughing).
I'm choking on this fucking tapioca ball.
I'm like (coughing).
I'm like, you gotta Heimlich maneuver me.
It was awful.
I spat out the boba in
the store. It was so bad.
I suck on it, and like
the whitest thing ever,
I went (coughing).
- That is the whitest story ever.
White man tries tapioca
for the first time.
- Literally spat it out.
And I was like, "I'm so sorry."
He's like, "No, it was funny."
And I'm like, "Oh, okay."
I'm like, "But the milk part tasted good.
Can we get rid of the balls?"
And he's like, "Yeah, we'll
just make you another one
without the balls."
"No, no, no, you don't have to."
He's like, "It's free, don't worry."
I'm like, oh, okay.
- I got you, bro.
- I was like, "Aw, okay, okay, okay."
- That's nice of him.
- Yeah, he's very, very nice.
- God, I remember when
the fucking initial boba
explosion happened in Japan.
- How did that happen?
Why did that happen?
- That's so weird, 'cause
the month we moved here,
it was like every boba store,
you would tell which boba store,
what was a boba store, sorry,
if it had a line outside.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, right.
- There were some boba stores
near my house at the time
where it was like, legit, on weekends,
it was legit like a four-hour wait.
- Yeah, I don't get it.
- And I'm like, what?
- I don't get it.
It's just bit a tea with some jelly.
- Man, did that die though.
- Oh, yeah.
- It fucking sped-run death.
- Dude, I like-
- Did it speed-run death?
I think it's still-
- Oh, yeah.
- No, you never see lines anymore.
- No, you go to a boba store now.
There's maybe one or two people there max.
- That's true, that's true.
Well, they're still a thing
in the UK from what I can see.
They still exist, the stores still exist-
- No, no, it's still around,
but it's not the hype.
The hype is nowhere near.
- It's just the hype,
but I mean, rightly so.
'Cause I thought it
was overrated the fuck.
- [Joey] I think so too.
- I didn't get what the
craze around it was.
- I mean, I drank a
shitload of it during uni,
because we had a boba store
near where we studied.
- [Connor] I get it.
- Yeah, but that was before the explosion.
- It lasts a while, 'cause it's cold.
You can kinda just sip
on it throughout the day
if you ever get a big one.
- Also, if you're a uni student,
it's a great sugar rush.
And also, it keeps you concentrated.
- I guess, everyone after a
while was, in Japan at least,
were like, all right,
back to Starbucks now.
- [Joey] Yeah, back to Starbucks.
- Back to the way life should've been.
- I just saw nothing but just iced tea,
or iced coffee, I don't know, maybe.
To me, it was like-
- But it's not fun.
There's no personality.
- I'm a hot boy.
I like my drinks hot.
I don't really like cold drinks that much.
- They had hot boba too
though, right, I think?
- Hot boba is just not the same.
- They have hot boba?
- It's not the same.
Yeah, I think they do.
- What?
- But it's not as good.
- I believe you can order
it with no ice sometimes.
You know when you can
customize your order?
- That's lukewarm though.
- That is true, that's lukewarm.
- That's like piss water.
- [Joey] Warm boba?
- Yeah, that's like pee water.
- Warm boba?
- [Joey] Gross.
- I don't know what maniac
would order a warm boba,
but it was an option in some
of the boba stores I've been to.
- If it was a specialty, I'd
be like, okay, if you say so.
- Was that a secret menu?
- [Garnt] The secret menu!
- Did you have to speak
Chinese to get that one?
It's like, got my Chinese friend.
Can I get the lukewarm boba?
It's like, aw, you know your shit.
- Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know how or why it exploded,
but I remember, not just in Japan,
but just pretty much everywhere in the UK,
everywhere in Thailand, you
just couldn't get away from it.
- Even in the States,
I remember it was huge.
- It was fashionable.
I think it's just a fashionable drink.
- Yeah, I guess so.
- It's Instagram-able.
That's it.
- Yeah.
- It's Instagram-able.
- Let's be honest, 2014
was all the Frappuccino.
That's what it was.
- That's true, that's true.
- It came out.
That was the thing.
Everyone just wants a photogenic drink,
and boba looked photogenic.
- But I feel Japan took
the photogenic-ness of boba
and just was trying to stretch it out
to such a high degree where
it was just so unnecessary-
- That's like everything in Japan now.
Everything is about taking photos.
Afternoon tea, I love my afternoon tea.
It's the most British
thing I've ever said.
I really, really enjoy going for tea
and having crumpets or scones.
- That is a weirdly popular
subculture in Japan, isn't it?
- It is, but everywhere I've
been just does it really badly.
- [Joey] Really?
- Okay, I mean, not
badly. It's hard to say.
- [Joey] Not as good.
- To me, afternoon tea is just as much
about the food you get as it is the tea.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And the food isn't great here.
- The food here looks so aesthetic.
- But it doesn't taste good.
- Yeah, yeah, that's
literally all they do.
They arrange it,
and they get these
beautiful colored things.
Then you take one bite of the quiche.
You're like, why does it taste bad?
- I actually agree.
Afternoon is one thing
that England does the best
that I've had so far,
because the afternoon tea
food is actually good,
whereas in Japan, every
time I've had afternoon tea,
it just looks pretty.
- Also, yeah, it's
gotta be layered, right?
The layers are to distinguish
the types of flavors.
Bottom is for sandwiches.
Then maybe you get the quiches
or the more savory kind of the dishes.
It's always sandwich at the bottom.
- Like pastries and stuff like that?
- So it's savory.
- You got the sweets
at the top.
- Savory, and then sweets.
But in Japan, it's sweets, sweets,
savory, and also sweets.
It's ridiculous.
'Cause normally, afternoon
tea, you kinda have it at,
we'd have it in the afternoon.
If it's a good place,
you can normally skip
lunch or dinner with it,
'cause it's quite a lot.
Some places even refill.
In the UK, they refill the sandwiches
or stuff in some places.
You can chow down.
If you liked the sandwiches,
or you liked whatever they're offering,
dude, it's good, it's so good.
You get your money's worth.
Expensive though.
In London, it's very expensive.
- [Joey] Yeah, I bet.
- It's good, it's really good.
- But it's an experience
you're paying for, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, I get that.
- One thing I've only seen
really in Asia as well,
going off the boba thing,
before, I guess, the boba craze took off-
- It's the most privileged thing
I've ever mentioned by the way.
I just realized that.
- What? Afternoon tea?
- I sound so privileged,
me being like, "The tea isn't
good enough, disgusting."
- [Joey] No sandwiches.
- I mean, it's one thing I
feel like Britain does well,
so I think it's a good-
- It's no Greggs though, is it?
- It's no Greggs.
- It's not Greggs.
But yeah, dessert cafes, that's one thing
I only saw in Asia.
- Oh, god.
- Oh, yeah.
- I don't know if there is more
dessert cafes in the UK now-
- Dessert buffets especially.
- Sorry?
- Dessert buffets.
- What's that?
- It's literally exactly that.
Think of a buffet, but it's all desserts.
- Yeah, 'cause whenever I'd hang out
with some of my friends in
Thailand, they'd be like,
"Oh, let's go to this dessert cafe."
I'm just like, wait.
To me, growing up in England,
dessert was something you have
at the end of the meal at a restaurant.
You don't go to a specific
place to eat dessert, right?
That concept was just alien to me.
To me, it still feels weird, right?
If I wanted dessert after a meal,
I would order it at the restaurant.
But you go to a dessert cafe,
it's like half a meal, you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you never go to a dessert cafe
after you finish eating at a restaurant,
but you go to a dessert cafe
at really weird times at a day.
- Three.
- Yeah, three or something.
I go to a dessert cafe,
I have the dessert,
and then it just fucks
with my eating schedule.
'Cause then I just don't want dinner,
but then it also doesn't
fill me up as well.
It's really weird.
- So you get hungry at 9 PM.
It's like a really weird
time where it's like,
oh, it's kinda too late to eat food.
- [Garnt] Yeah, right.
- But I know I won't be able to sleep,
'cause I'm gonna get hungry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- No, I get that.
- I don't know, I just
don't feel satisfied
if I've eaten a lot of something sweet.
But when I eat a savory
meal, I just feel happy.
- I just feel sick if I eat
too much sweet stuff now.
I was always like that though.
I could never eat too...
I like sweets, but I could
never eat too much of it,
'cause then I'd just get...
I'd be filled up, but then that feeling
of being filled up by sweet shit,
it just made me feel really ill,
which just made me wanna
eat regular food anyway.
- Man, I said this a year or two ago,
but man, I still don't
like themed cafes in Japan,
the collaboration cafes.
The food-
- Because of the food?
- The food and drink is a joke.
- It looks good.
- That's the thing.
I hate the fact that we're
turning food impractical.
Okay, wow, we put a little...
I went to the Square Enix one.
- Oh, yeah.
- And then they made me a latte.
And I was like, this
latte tastes really bad.
But they put a Slime on it,
so I guess now it's worth $9.
It's like, what?
- I've been to so many themed cafes,
'cause Aki loves going to them.
- I know.
- 'Cause she makes content out of it,
so it's understandable.
I think the only good one
where I would actually go back
for the food is the Kirby Cafe.
I know it's good-
- Lies.
- Sus, sus.
- No, no.
I know it's good because-
- The biggest Kirby fan of all-
- No, no, no, no, no, hear me out.
- Says the Kirby Cafe-
- Hear me out.
- Has the best food.
- It does.
- What a coincidence, Joey.
- It legitimately does, and I know
I'm not the only one who thinks that,
because it was a temporary
thing at fucking Tokyo Skytree,
but now they made it a permanent thing.
So you know if a themed
cafe turns permanent,
that's how you know that the food is good.
Because if the food sucks,
then people don't come back.
There's a novelty to it
that's really short lived.
And once you've experienced all the food
and you've experienced
that themed cafe's style and everything,
and you've grabbed all
the fucking merch you can,
because there's always a merch
shop attached to it as well,
then you're not gonna go back.
- I don't know, 'cause to me,
it's like the food itself is the art.
Don't draw all over my steak.
Don't reassemble the carrots
to look like a smiley face.
I'm not a toddler.
- But I think that's why
I like the Kirby Cafe,
because the Kirby Cafe,
they don't fuck around the food.
They fuck around with the cutlery.
So the plates are shaped in certain ways,
or the cups are shaped in certain ways.
But the actual food itself is normal
once you put it on a regular plate.
- I don't know if I'm like
a Scrooge or something,
just don't enjoy fun or whatever,
but I just don't want people making faces
or shit out with my food.
I don't want my food to be a toy.
- [Joey] No, I get that.
- I'm exactly the same way where,
if I go to a themed something
of something I'm a fan of,
then I don't want them to
fuck around with the food.
- Right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Look, look, I'm here for a good time
to enjoy the thing I like.
- I'll buy the merch.
Give me cool merch.
Give me cool exclusive
merch that I can buy.
- What better way to get one with the show
than to digest the show.
- Oh, dude, fucking typical example
is when we went to the
"Baki" exhibit, right?
And I saw this poster that was like,
oh, just down the block,
there is the Baki Cafe,
a "Baki" themed cafe.
- Oh, god.
- And my friend and I were like,
'cause it was hitting around
lunch time, early afternoon.
We were like, all right, let's
go check it out, all right?
Let's go see the menu.
And I saw the menu, and I was like,
this is the laziest
attempt at a themed cafe.
One of them was Retsu
Kaiou's Neapolitan pasta.
And I'm like, when does
Retsu ever eat Napoleon pasta
in fucking "Baki?"
- It's like they are really
fucking stretching it.
They're really stretching
it to make it on brand.
- It's Mickey Mouse's
world-famous lasagna.
He loves lasagna.
- One of them was Yuujirou's cappuccino.
It didn't even have Yuujirou's face on it.
It was literally just a cappuccino.
- $9.
- What makes this Yuujirou?
- That's the thing about-
- $10.
- So many themed cafes are mental in Japan
where they have a dish on the menu
that's just like fucking
Rin's special curry
from "Fate/stay night."
And I'm just like, when did this happen?
How is this on brand?
Why did you just add a...
You literally just added a
character to a random dish.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
- You call it a brand?
They call it branded.
- I find it insulting.
You're insulting my intelligence.
- You're insulting my fandom.
- You think I'm just gonna buy this
because you put this kaiju on it?
I'll take two.
- If you had put the
fucking Neapolitan pasta
in front of me, I would've been like,
oh, it's just a regular Neapolitan pasta.
Do you think if they were like,
"But it's Retsu Kaiou's Neapolitan pasta,"
then I'd be like, "Well,
fucking sign me up then!
I'm gonna eat the shit out of this!"
- This is why, when you go to
Wolfgang Puck's restaurant,
he doesn't serve fucking
smiley faces on his steak.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I just don't want that, I don't want it.
- It's like the steak
just has the initials.
- If you went to a rely nice restaurant...
Yeah, just initials burnt into the steak,
you'd be like, what the fuck this this?
What is this? Is this a horse?
Are you branding it? Was it running away?
What's going on?
- This is our steak.
- I just don't like that.
To me, if a food is done well,
it itself is so beautiful,
and I'll pay for it.
Just have the decor of your cafe,
have everything else be themed.
Everything else but the food.
Don't fuck with that.
- Just have cool cutlery.
Have a cool vibe.
Have a cool aesthetic.
Make it feel like you're at the place.
- If it's Kirby, make it so
that the toilet is Kirby,
and I can lift up his mouth.
And I can sit and shit in Kirby's mouth.
- Yeah, right, but I think
that's what I appreciated
about the Kirby Cafe
was that they didn't fuck
around with the food.
They fucked around with the cutlery,
which you can then buy at
the fucking merch store.
So I was like, oh, cool.
This is a thing I can use in my kitchen.
And it's kinda neat and dope,
and I don't have to make
a fucking Kirby-themed-
- Yeah, you'll have to go
if you come to Japan at some point.
I'm sure there will be tons.
- Yeah, please, Kirby Cafe's great.
- There's always a bunch.
They're rotating.
- For me, especially when it's cafes
especially that are paired with
exhibits or whatever, right?
Just give me some good merch.
- Didn't they have the
"Pen Pineapple Pen" cafe?
- Yeah, I went to that.
- Did they actually?
- Yeah.
- No fucking way.
- I made a video on it.
- Oh, god.
- Yeah, you did, right?
- Yeah, I made a video on it.
- How long ago was this?
- When was "Pen Pineapple Apple Pen" made?
Six years ago?
- Six years ago or something.
- I think it was 2016.
Yeah, they made a-
- That's how popular it
was. They made a cafe.
- They made a popup of
"Pen Pineapple Apple Pen."
I think it was at Tokyo Skytree,
or Tokyo Tower, whichever one it was.
Yeah, you go in, and all of the menu items
spelled out P-P-A-P.
That was the only-
- That was it?
- Yep, they didn't even have any pineapple
or apple-based products, and I'm like,
I feel like you really
missed the ball here.
- Paprika, it's paprika, right?
- It was a "Pen Pineapple Apple
Pen" burger, and I'm like,
what does this have to do with
"Pen Pineapple Apple Pen?"
- With zero pineapple in the burger.
- Yeah, no pineapple in
the burger, no apple-
- That's good though. I
don't like pineapple burgers.
- I don't mind it if it's done well.
But even then, they couldn't
even put the effort to do that.
The thing I felt the most
sorry about was the fact that,
there was two clerks who were
standing behind the counter,
and they looked so dead inside,
because "Pen Pineapple Apple
Pen" was playing on repeat
in the store all day.
- Oh my god.
- I was there for a couple of hours.
By minute 20, I was like,
I wanna get the fuck out of here.
Shove a pen in my ear.
Just blur out the sound.
They looked so dead.
- That's kind of how I feel.
All of the truck drivers that drive
around fucking Harajuku or whatever,
and they have to drive around promoting
these idols or whatever.
- Oh, yeah.
- Or this latest album.
- Yeah, have we spoke about...
I swear we've mentioned it.
There's these trucks
that drive around Japan
where they'll play music really loudly.
- [Joey] They're called
(speaking in foreign language),
or decorative trucks.
- [Connor] Yeah, and they just blind you.
And they're awful, they're awful.
- [Joey] It's basically just
a moving billboard basically.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, basically.
- It's weird in Japan
how you can't make noise
in your own apartment, but
anyone can make as much noise
as they want on the street.
It's really weird, right?
- Someone can come around
selling hot potatoes
and intrude our streams.
- People running for government
just scream in public.
- Yeah.
- It's just like, what year are we in?
Don't you have social
media you could promote on?
- No, no.
- No, I'm sure you're really connected
with the youth of today
by driving around a truck and screaming.
- What do they expect
for everyone to come out
of their houses is like,
"Guys, honey, wake up.
The new politician's in town."
- I mean, even if it's
older people, right?
Well, they're not gonna
get up just to go outside
to listen to you drive by.
- And maybe that's why they're loud.
Otherwise, they're not gonna hear it,
so they just broadcast to all the houses.
- Honestly, probably.
- We gotta make it through
the hearing aids somehow.
- It trends in an interesting
spot where they have to,
political people have to try and go
towards the older generation.
So all the techniques they
use seem archaic as fuck,
but it's the only way
they can get elected.
'Cause if you're not
in someone's letterbox,
they're not gonna get on Twitter.
Weird, isn't it? Weird, isn't it?
The whole political system is just catered
towards old people.
- What I just don't understand though is,
yeah, I'm sure they're being
loud as fuck on the street,
so that, again, as you were saying,
it can reach the old peoples' ears, right?
Because a lot of people,
as old age comes naturally,
you become hard of hearing.
And yet these same old people can hear
the tiniest creak from
upstairs and be like,
"Oh my god, that's too fucking loud.
How dare they walk so
loud in my apartment!"
Meanwhile, I'm having a
really hard time hearing
this fucking politician on 17 megaphones
just drive past my house.
I need them to turn up
a little bit louder.
- Well, I don't know what...
Are there any laws around how much noise
you can make in Japan?
- Isn't it past 10?
- Past 10?
- Or nine?
- It's something like that, I don't know.
- [Connor] I don't know.
- I feel, half the time,
people just don't follow those laws.
And there's always exceptions to the rule.
You could have like a bunch of...
How come all these loud ass bikes
that drive through neighborhoods
and not be fucking called on by the cops?
- Does your neighborhood have a gang
of old Japanese grandmas
who are just like the real-
- What do you mean?
- The leaders of that
fucking street or whatever.
- It's 'cause you have a house.
- Oh, yeah, I have a house.
- Yeah, yeah, you're
in a neighborhood area.
- I'm in an apartment.
- Okay.
- Yeah, I'm in an apartment as well.
- Yeah, 'cause Meilyne warns me about this
before I was moving in the house.
She was like, "Be careful about the posse
of old Japanese grandmas."
And I'm just like, "What are
you talking about, Meilyne?
What are you talking about?"
Lo and behold, now I've noticed
there is this group of Japanese grandmas
who seem to run the neighborhood.
I don't know how this happened.
I don't know why this happened.
But you do one thing wrong,
maybe you take a garbage
out just a bit too early.
You see them, you see them eyeing you.
You see them eyeing you, right?
I can tell.
Anytime me and Sydney come out,
sometimes they're just gossiping together.
You know when you can feel
someone gossiping about you,
that's every time me and
Sydney go out of the house.
They're always in the same corner.
It's the same group of Japanese
grandmas, and I remember-
- We should wait for them to say hi.
- Yeah, yeah, you should-
- No, I do, I do.
- For those people, what I've learned
is that you just need
to be ignorantly happy
and friendly towards them.
And then they'll start to be like,
oh, maybe they're actually all right.
Maybe we'll take them off
the hit list, you know?
- Okay, I feel like I've been put...
I was friendly enough, right?
- There's so much moist-
- Sorry.
- Amount of speaking here.
(Connor moaning)
- I feel like I've been
put on a hit list now,
because I did unfortunately
take the garbage out
on the wrong day.
One day, one day.
- Being on a Japanese
hit list is just like,
I'll give you, at worst, a
passive aggressive note one day.
- Yeah, I got that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Did you really?
- Yeah, remember?
In my old apartment, I got
that English-written note.
- Yeah, that's the worst you'll get.
- [Joey] Yeah, that's
the worst you'll get.
- They say they'll kick you out,
and they'll tell the housing company.
- And then I need (speaking
in foreign language)
reverse Uno card, and then they shut up.
- The housing company's
not gonna kick you out.
- No, of course not.
- Unless you are actually taking the piss.
But if you're just walking,
the housing company's
not gonna give a fuck.
- They'd be like, okay, granny.
- They'd be like, all right.
- Simmer down, come on now.
- So yeah, one day, normally,
we take our garbage out
either the night before or the morning of.
I don't know what's custom
in Japanese neighborhoods.
- It depends on your area.
- Yeah, normally, it's like,
I think, the morning of,
but I remember, I think, I
woke up slightly late that day.
So how it worked in my place is that,
the garbage is one day.
And then the recyclables is the next day.
- Yeah, I hated that.
- I think that's most places.
- Yeah, yeah, so I thought
I was just on the cusp
of getting the recyclables
out on the right day,
'cause it's garbage,
recyclables, then garbage again.
So I thought I was just on the cusp.
Maybe the garbage truck hadn't come yet.
So I go out to the garbage spot,
and I see some bags there.
I was like, oh, great,
I still made it in time.
And so I put the recyclables
out, went back in my house,
and just continue about my day.
I get a ring on my doorbell.
- Oh no.
- I get a ring on my doorbell.
- No way.
- And I'm just like, oh, it
must be a delivery or something.
- Yeah.
- I open the door, and it's
three old Japanese grandmas-
- Oh my god.
- Just staring at me.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, I am serious.
- [Joey] Oh my god!
- And I see my bag of recyclables
right in front of my door.
- [Joey] Right.
- I mean, they nicely
enough explained to me
that I had missed the time
and it was just the wrong day
to bring out the recyclables,
but it kinda felt like
some fucking loan sharks
outside my door being like-
- It'd be a shame if this
were to happen again.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's like repo men.
You do it again, we're taking everything.
- They are basically the gangsters
that run the neighborhood, you know?
I felt like I just missed out on paying
the protection money of the day.
It's like, shame what would happen-
- America has the Crips and the Bloods.
We have the Grannies.
(all laugh)
Fear them, they control everything.
- Yeah, they're the real...
It's like the fucking Sopranos, right?
It's the Japanese Sopranos, right?
The old Japanese grandmas-
- Did you take the recycling out today?
- I heard some really
strict crazy grandmas
can get pissed off when,
you know on cardboard boxes?
- [Joey And Garnt] Yeah.
- Like the Amazon labels and stuff,
they get pissed off you
don't take those off.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I've heard of some
grandmas that get like,
they're like, how dare you.
Even though it doesn't make a difference.
- No, of course not.
- This is why I love living
in an apartment building.
I can just take it down whenever I want.
No recycling day.
No garbage day.
It's like, whenever you
have garbage, take it down.
Cardboard's the worst,
'cause when you're moving in,
it literally is like cardboard city.
And it's just stacks
upon stacks upon stack.
I'm waiting for the day when you're like,
well, what's that in the corner, Connor?
Well, it's the wall of cardboard actually.
It's one of the main
attractions of the apartment.
I have so much cardboard, in fact,
that I could probably house
everyone in the half of Japan.
- Yeah, I mean, that's the thing where,
I remember when I was
moving in, I felt like,
if you missed the day of
the cardboard collection,
then you were just fucked, right?
- Yeah, but also you feel like,
am I taking the piss
with this much cardboard?
I have a two-meter-high
stack of cardboard.
Am I taking up too much
cardboard? Is that allowed?
What's the limit on how much
recycling I can recycle?
- I remember the only time
I had a granny experience
when I was moving into my
current place was when,
it was like the first
week I was moving in,
and it was like the
shitload of cardboard thing.
And cardboard day comes around.
I'm just like, finally, here we go.
This is where the cleansing starts.
So I take out way too much cardboard,
probably fucking half
the Amazon rainforest
worth of cardboard, right?
- [Connor] Naturally.
- And then, the next morning,
I come out to leave for the office, right?
And a grandma stops me.
And I'm like, oh no.
- Uh oh, uh oh.
- And she points at the
mountain of cardboard,
and she's like, "That's
all your cardboard, right?"
And I was like, "I mean, not all of it."
- Oh, come on, love,
it's like 90%. Fuck off.
- Yeah, most of it.
And she's like, "I think
that you're really causing
the rubbish people a lot of trouble
with that much cardboard."
And then I just reverse
Uno card, and I'm like,
"I moved in yesterday."
Puts on sunglasses, walks off.
But legit, she was just
like, "Oh, I'm sorry then.
I'm sorry about that."
But that felt good.
That was the one time
where I trumped the granny.
I was like, you don't control it!
- Silence!
- Silence, woman!
- [Ashley] You can actually,
some moving companies say call them up.
- Yeah, and take the cardboard.
- Yeah, yeah, I did that, but even they,
I had so much cardboard
that the moving company
could only take so much cardboard.
'Cause I moved into a much bigger place,
and I needed to buy all this new furniture
to fill up the space.
But it felt good.
It felt good to reverse Uno card a granny.
- Basically, they think
organized crime in Japan
is the Yakuza, no.
- [Joey] It's the grandmas.
- It's the Japanese grannies
in your neighborhood.
Watch out, make sure
you don't piss them off.
Otherwise, you're gonna
be having a bad time.
- I've been living here for 60 years.
I know every nook and
cranny of these streets.
- Literally the day after
they came, I came back home,
and they had slid this in my letterbox,
just the schedule of the
garbage for the week,
and the garbage collection.
- No.
- That's so passive aggressive.
- I was just like, oh,
they're sending me a message.
They're literally sending me a message.
- You turn over the
note, and they're like,
get this wrong again, you're dead.
Don't fuck it up again, Garnt.
- Gonna wake up in bed with
a decapitated horse head.
Get the garbage day right
next time. Don't fuck up.
- You'll have a dead
salmon at your front door.
- It's like, you better take
this out on the right day.
- What day does oily
containers go, Garnt? Hmm?
- The ultimate test.
- A shampoo bottle?
A shampoo bottle is not recycling, Garnt.
- Oh my god.
- I love it, you have
this spreadsheet of items
that very specifically
cannot be recycled and stuff.
- I have an app for it, dude.
- [Connor] Oh my god.
- Yeah, our ward created
an app being like,
if you put in a certain item,
it tells you exactly
what day to bring it out.
- What sucks is that there's like,
some items, you're like,
what the fuck is this?
You know, like styrofoam, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Have you had that packaging that's thin?
It's like a paper styrofoam?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- What the fuck is this?
Is this burnable?
Is this paper, or is this-
- Plastic?
- I don't know what this is.
This is a mystery.
And every time I ask anyone,
they're like, "I have no idea."
I think it's burnable, but no one's 100%.
Everyone's like, "Dude,
it's not gonna matter.
Just put it in the burnable."
- That's the thing.
There's all these rules that are laid out
that the grannies will enforce you on.
But when you put it all into
a fucking bag and put it out.
- [Garnt] Of course.
- I heard that apparently the recycling,
even though they make
you sort it very strict,
that actually when it goes
to the plant apparently,
I don't know how true this
is, that it's not actually,
they don't recycle it as
well as you'd think they are.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I would believe that.
- I mean, fair enough.
But fuck, dude, one time I went down
to my recycling thing in my current place.
I thought, hmm.
I was putting out my
bottles in my bottle thing,
and I noticed that there was 10-plus
Bombay Sapphire gin bottles.
And I was like, who has drank
this much Bombay Sapphire?
This is a lot of gin.
- It wasn't you, right?
- No, it wasn't me.
I was gonna say-
- I thought that was you.
- As another person who
enjoys Bombay Sapphire gin,
I was like, huh, I wonder who's
bought this much Bombay...
I'm gonna keep saying
it, it's very satisfying.
Bombay Sapphire gin.
- Clearly, there's another
British person in your building.
- I was like, either somebody's
running a bar secretly
in their apartment that specializes
in Bombay Sapphire cocktails.
- Or someone had a good night.
- Or there's a really
depressed British person
somewhere in this apartment building
who is really, really spending
a lot of money on gin.
I just thought, why
would you have this many?
They're all neatly stacked,
almost like a Jenga-esque stacking style.
This is definitely one
person who brought...
I wonder, did they collect
them for a long time,
and they thought, no, this is ridiculous.
I can't collect this many bottles.
'Cause some people will keep
their alcohol containers
afterwards as a memory, but I guess,
when you drink too much, you're
like, okay, this is just-
- How many Bombay Sapphires is too many?
- I just thought, I was
like, this is a lot.
I'm like, what's going on here?
I wonder, I was like, what a weird trash.
You ever see peoples' trash,
and you think, what's going on?
- Oh, yeah.
- What's going on with that?
- Many times.
I remember the weirdest one I saw was,
it was a vacuum cleaner
that had been perfectly cut
in half down the middle.
I was like, how does that happen?
- Someone's like, damn, man, I
just wanna see what's inside.
- Yeah, it was a Dyson.
It was the body of a Dyson,
but it'd been perfectly
split down the middle.
But there was only one half.
And I'm like, where did the other half go?
- Sounds like some serial killer shit.
- It was just one half?
- It was only one half.
For five minutes, I was
kinda looking around seeing.
I wonder where the other half is.
I couldn't find it.
So he's either kept the other half,
or I've witnessed some crucial evidence
of a crime scene or something.
I don't know what.
- That's so specific.
- It was the weirdest thing.
At least, I was like,
oh, well, now I know
what's inside of a Dyson.
- That's something you'd
see for a YouTube channel.
- Yeah, right.
What's inside of a Dyson?
- What's inside of a Dyson?
What if I cut this Dyson in perfect half?
- I just wanna know how they did it.
It's either someone has a laser cutter
inside of their house,
or they just went ham with a saw.
I don't know what it was.
- Either they have a saw in their house,
or it's somewhere else,
and then they brought half a Dyson
to your apartment building.
And then they decided that they
are done with half a Dyson,
and they're gonna throw it away.
- It was the weirdest thing I'd ever seen.
- It's so annoying having to
get rid of big stuff in Japan.
- It is.
- You buy those stupid
stickers from the company.
And then, you can't throw
out, if it's bigger than,
I think, 30 centimeters in my apartment.
- Yeah, something like that.
- Which is nothing.
There's so many things that
are 30 centimeters or bigger.
And if you wanna throw it
away, you have to book.
And it's normally like three
weeks away if you're lucky.
- Yeah, usually, it's like a month.
- Now I've figured out a genius strat,
which is just break the thing
down to below 30 centimeters.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you're good.
You know how, in prison movies,
when they escape from prison,
that they start dumping
the soil one by one
in the courtyard or something?
It's like, all right, you
gotta break this cabinet
into small pieces and slowly
recycle it every week.
- I saw that the other day actually.
- People do it, because they
don't wanna deal with...
'Cause this shit is so annoying.
- Someone had disposed of an office chair
one part at a time.
- I get it, I get it.
- [Joey] That's so genius.
- I remember seeing, I would
go take the garbage out,
and one day, I saw the
bottom off, the wheels part.
And I'm just like, why is
someone just getting rid
of the fucking wheels part?
And then, the next week, I
go to put the garbage again,
and it's the seat.
And then it's the seat.
Someone's just playing
Jenga with office chairs.
And then, next week, lo and
behold, it's the backrest.
- It's slow, but it's effective.
- This is the exact
reason why I bought a saw.
I am not kidding.
I bought a saw just to saw shit in half,
so I don't have to deal with this.
- I had a lot of wooden
shit, and I'm just like,
I'm not paying to get rid of
this fucking wooden plank.
I'm just gonna saw this bitch in half.
- It's also annoying, 'cause
you have to measure it exactly.
If it's even a little bit
off, they won't take it.
And then you gotta wait
another three weeks
and buy those stupid sticker things again.
I don't wanna do this.
- I had a metallic coat hanger,
or a coat rack kind of thing.
And of course, it was way too big,
even if I took the parts off.
So what did I do?
I put it back up, I put it on my balcony,
and just let the weather wear
it down as much as possible,
to the point where I could
just snap it in half.
- You let it rust?
- I just let it rust to shit.
And then I grab the saw or
just snap it half to the sides.
I'm like, perfect.
- Just let nature take its course.
(Joey laughs)
Erosion.
- Three months later, I was like,
all right, I can finally take this out.
- It's the worst way to recycle something,
but I respect the effort you'd go
to not deal with the bureaucracy.
- Yeah, dude, it probably
would've taken just as long
to fucking book a time
to throw this fucking coat hanger out.
- Yeah, I just don't wanna
deal with it, you know?
- Or I just wait for someone
to come over and be like,
"Do you want this shitty
thing I don't need?
Just take it please."
- Dude, they make me
feel like such a bastard
for using batteries.
I just wanna use some AA batteries,
and they make it seem
like I was using some kind
of radioactive material the
way they made me get rid of it.
I'm like, what's wrong with me?
- I don't think I've
ever properly gotten rid
of my batteries, right?
Because I'm just like,
okay, I'll get rid of them
next time, another time.
So I have a fucking
drawer just full of used-
- [Joey] Dead batteries?
- Used dead batteries
that I've not been able
to get rid of, because I've always-
- That is the most troll
drawer in existence.
- Yeah.
- Huh?
- Sure, we've got a whole drawer full
of batteries sitting here.
Go and grab a pair.
None of them are working, Garnt!
- That's what you should do as a joke.
Just get one actually working battery
and put it in the drawer, and be like,
"There is one working battery."
- Find the working battery.
- Good luck.
- Trash day special.
- I'm gonna get rid of it someday,
but I just keep forgetting the day
to get rid of the batteries properly.
- It's like the most fucked up "Saw" trap.
There is one working
battery. You have 15 minutes.
- Find the working battery.
- Oh my god.
- I don't really use a lot of batteries,
but for a lot of the
filming stuff that we have-
- Yeah, it's basically
all for the filming stuff.
- It's all for mics, camera accessories.
It's all batteries.
It's really annoying 'cause you have
to get batteries for
that, and it kinda sucks.
It's like, get rechargeable ones.
It's like, yeah, but I
always forget to recharge.
- Yeah, but then if you
get rechargeable ones,
you forget to recharge
them before the shoots,
which is unfortunate.
- And luckily, you can buy AAA batteries
everywhere in Japan.
It's pretty good for that.
It's pretty good.
Always done well.
- Anything else you guys
been up to this week?
- I'm just trying to think.
- I've watched anime.
I finished "Odd Taxi."
- Oh, you finished "Odd Taxi?"
That's surprising.
Did you watch it in subbed or dubbed?
- Subbed, it was good, I liked it.
- Oh, nice.
- Yeah?
- A very fun show.
I don't know how they're
gonna make a movie.
- [Joey] Oh, yeah, they are
making a movie, aren't they?
- Yeah, I was surprised
when they announced
that they were making a movie,
just because it felt like it
just wrapped everything up.
- I was like, we're done, aren't we?
- Also it weirdly seemed like,
I didn't think it was as
popular on the surface-
- Did you watch it?
- As it made it out to be.
I watched it, yeah.
- Did you finish it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- How have we never talked about this?
- I don't know.
I thought I told you I finished it.
- No, you didn't.
I would remember.
- It's because it's so rare.
- I would remember if you told me
you finished an anime, Joey.
What the fuck?
- I liked it. I thought it was good.
- Yeah, I liked it. It was good.
But yeah, again, I was surprised,
not only because, yeah, as you said,
the show wrapped up
nicely where it was like,
how are they gonna make a movie out of it?
But also, it's like, I don't know,
I feel "Odd Taxi" was one of those shows
where it got really
popular from word of mouth.
I was like, did it really get that popular
to warrant a movie?
- I don't know how popular it got,
because I remember when
I made my video on it,
I made it 'cause no one was
talking about it at all.
- I thought it was kinda the underdog.
- Everyone who watches it I know likes it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's a great show.
- But that's the thing.
It's one of those shows where
I feel you start watching it,
because someone who gave it a go was like,
"It was really fucking good."
- Yeah, I feel like it had a
similar arc to "Made in Abyss,"
because when "Made in Abyss" came out,
no one was watching
"Made in Abyss" at all,
'cause everyone saw the art style,
and everyone was just like,
oh, this is a children's show.
- Children's show.
- Children's show, which
couldn't be more further
from the truth honestly.
- There's a lot of children in the show.
- I mean, yeah, it is a children's show
in some sense of the word.
- That's one for the kids.
- One for the whole family.
- They can relate. The
children can relate.
- The children can relate.
But yeah, I mean, that was another show
that really spread through word of mouth,
and then eventually it
won Anime of the Year
the year it came out as well.
"Odd Taxi," I feel, had a similar thing
where it didn't really have much promotion
or anything like that,
at least not that I could
see outside of Japan.
In Japan, it actually had
some kind of decent promotion.
I remember, when it was airing,
every time you'd go in a taxi,
they would have an "Odd
Taxi" advertisement.
- Did they really?
- Yeah, yeah, did you not see?
- No, I don't remember that.
- No, I didn't see.
- They'd always have it playing
in the little TVs that they
have on the back of the taxis.
- Did they?
- At least I did.
I saw a bunch of 'em.
- I didn't go in enough taxis to know.
- Did I talk about "Tokyo Revengers?"
I watched that.
- I think you-
- You have not talked
about "Tokyo Revengers."
- Have we not?
- Maybe not on episode.
- I was trying to watch
all the animes of the year
that were nominated.
- When did you get time to watch anime?
- I mean, an episode here and there.
It's very sporadic.
I was like, oh, "Sonny
Boy" looks kind of shit.
- Yeah, you're not going
to enjoy "Sonny Boy."
- I looked at it, and I was like,
oh, yeah, it's for those anime fans
that think that they're really intelligent
and want something deep.
- Your IQ wasn't high enough.
- At the end of the day,
they're just anime fans.
- I'll tell you who
would enjoy "Sonny Boy."
I think you would really
enjoy "Sonny Boy" actually.
- What, you're not the first person
to say that to me for some reason.
I don't know if I should be offended.
- No, no, you shouldn't be.
- There's a category of shows.
And to me, I took one look at
"Sonny Boy," and I was like,
oh, this is what fucking Reddit anime fans
are gonna be like,
"This is the best anime
of the year actually."
- I listened to two
soundtrack songs from it,
and I was like, okay,
if the soundtrack is as
good as the actual show,
I think I'm gonna enjoy this.
- I just cannot stand shows
where I feel like people like it
just to be pretentious.
And that's one of those shows
that I felt like the fans
make me wanna not watch it
and despise it more than the show.
- Yeah, I get that, I get that.
- I don't even know if
I enjoyed "Sonny Boy."
It's a really fucking weird show,
and it left an impression on me.
Whether I enjoyed it or not-
- Oh, that sounds like
something I would enjoy.
- Yeah, I watched it, and I'm just like,
this is such a Joey show.
- What would you give it out of 10?
- I don't even fucking know.
- A five?
- To me, it's still-
- Five, four, three, two, one?
- To me, it's still sinking in.
- What does that mean?
What does that fucking mean it's still...
What is it?
- I got the perfect analogy.
Have you watched "Donnie Darko?"
- Yeah.
- What did you think of it?
- I liked "Donnie Darko."
- What did you like about it?
- Gosh, it's been so long.
- Exactly!
- I remember I liked it.
It's been a very long time
since I watched "Donnie Darko."
- Oh, fuck, that's one
of my favorite movies.
- Okay, so it's kinda like that.
- Can you watch it so
that I don't feel bad
about shitting on it?
'Cause right now, I just feel
like I'm shitting into the void.
- What, "Sonny Boy?"
- It's like "86."
Yeah, yeah, it's like "86."
When I shit on "86," I thought,
oh, no one's gonna contest me on this.
Turned out everyone got really-
- Meanwhile, the entire internet.
- Everyone got really fucking angry
that I didn't like "86."
But to be fair, I watched
eight episodes of that,
and it was boring as shit.
That's "86's" fault.
- "Sonny Boy" is just 12?
- "Sonny Boy" is just 12 episodes.
Actually, 'cause I remember watching
the first three episodes of "Sonny Boy,"
thought it was boring as fuck.
I thought it was boring as fuck.
- Okay, if you think that,
then, holy shit, I'm gonna be giga-bored.
- This is like fucking arthouse
fucking pretentious shit.
And then the soundtrack
got recommended to me,
and I'm just like, holy fucking shit.
This soundtrack just is everything I want.
It's a lot of soft rock,
alternative rock in the soundtrack.
I mean, you've listened to some tracks.
And I'm just like, I kinda
wanna watch this show
just 'cause of the soundtrack.
- I found it because I was
buying a bunch of vinyls.
On the front page of the store,
the online store that I
go to to buy my vinyls,
it just would not leave the front page.
And I was like, what is
this "Sonny Boy" thing?
So I went onto YouTube real
quick, looked up one song,
and I was like, yep, sold.
- Yeah, right, right.
- This is lit.
- The best thing I could
say is the soundtrack
just sets the vibe of the anime.
- [Joey] Okay, yeah.
- Where it's less about the plot points,
and it's more about the
feeling that it gives you.
- Did you end up finishing it?
- Yeah, I did end up finishing it.
I mean, I finished it,
and I didn't know what to think about it.
I knew some of the ideas
presented in "Sonny Boy,"
it's one of those shows
that you don't know
exactly what you think immediately,
but I just remember some scenes.
- So is it kinda like
"FLCL" in that sense?
- Yeah, yeah, kinda like "FLCL"
where is just like "FLCL,"
"Donnie Darko," that kinda thing,
where you watch it and you're like,
I don't really know what I watched,
but some parts of it just
really stick with you
and just refuse to leave.
That's how I feel with "Sonny Boy."
- Do you think it deserves to be nominated
for an Anime of the Year?
- I don't think it
deserved to be nominated
for Anime of the Year?
- Didn't it win the Reddit
one though, the Reddit anime-
- Of course, it did!
Arthouse pretentious type of anime?
- It won the Reddit's,
not the user awards.
- No, the critics.
- The critic award.
- Oh my god!
- Which does not help its image at all.
The Reddit armchair
critics gave it the award
for anime of the year.
- I hate bashing on low-hanging
fruit, but yeah, I mean,
that is sometimes normally an
indication where I'm like...
- Yeah, I mean-
- Whenever I say "Donnie Darko" is one
of my favorite movies, I'm waiting for it.
I'm dangling the low-hanging fruit.
- We know it's normally Joey.
Joey's normally that guy in our podcast
who's the pretentious arthouse media guy.
- Yeah, I am, I am.
- With "Donnie Darko," did
you like it immediately?
- No, no.
I only liked it maybe after my second
or third viewing of it.
- I was so young when I watched it.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly, right.
- Yeah, that was the problem.
When I first watched it,
I was maybe 13, 14 years old, right?
When you watch those
kinds of movies at 13, 14,
you don't know what the fuck's going on.
All you think is, oh, creepy bunny, wow.
But then I watched it
again when I was 17, 18,
which is the peak of pretentiousness
when it comes to consuming media.
- I definitely had that phase as well.
- Do you understand "Donnie Darko?"
- Only after I watched a fuck-load
of analysis videos on it.
I had a friend who
recommended me "Donnie Darko"
during high school or middle school,
who was a massive fan of it.
He would tell me his theories on it,
and we would kinda bounce off ideas.
I think that's the reason why I like
a lot of those kinds of
media, because it's like,
especially when you have another person,
or a group of people to discuss it
and kinda theorize and hypothesize like,
oh, this might be this, or
this might be that, whatever.
That's kind of fun.
And then, once you actually sit down
and read into what it's actually about,
according to the creator or whatever,
then you just realize,
oh, it's not as deep
as all these fucking pretentious
critics made it out to be.
- My favorite thing is
when people speculate
about media and stuff.
And then the creator was
like, "No, that's not it."
And then they're like, no, no, no.
No, I don't think you
understood what you did.
I think it's actually this, sir.
- Literally the "Evangelion" fan base.
- Yeah, that's the EVA.
- It's literally like, no, no!
My theory is right please!
I think those anime don't appeal to me
as much unfortunately.
- No, and I totally don't blame you.
- No, it doesn't even appeal to me.
I have to be in a really specific mood
that comes along once a
year or once every two years
where I'm just like, I
just wanna watch something
and just not understand it
and make me feel things that are-
- I mean, the thing I
like about this podcast
is that the viewers can align
who they trust's opinion
on a show based on what
type of media they like.
If you're more to me, and
I'm like, I don't like "86,"
you shouldn't then trust
my opinion for other anime.
That show weirdly, people
are obsessed with it.
And I just didn't enjoy it.
And I didn't know
anything about the series.
I didn't know anyone was talking about it.
I just didn't like it.
- I think part of being a good critic,
online at least, or part
of being a good critic is,
acknowledging that you have tastes,
'cause people look at people
who talk about media online,
and they should be like,
you should be able to judge
every single piece of
media objectively, equally.
You should be able to
judge them with no bias.
And I'm just like, that's
completely bullshit.
- Yeah, you're not a fucking robot.
- When I look at, for
example, Dunkey for example,
when I look at one of
his video game reviews,
I know exactly what his taste is.
And that gives me a better perspective
than a lot of fucking
IGN reviewers, right?
Because at least when Dunkey...
I think, recently, I saw his review
of "Horizon: Forbidden West."
He didn't like completely-
- He shat on it.
He did shit on it.
- Okay, he shat on it.
Not completely compared
to some JRPGs for example.
I saw his criticisms,
and I was just like, wow.
I can completely understand
why he feels this way.
Me, knowing what kind of gamer he is-
- I understand.
- I understand, and that
gives me a better perspective
of what this game is like
compared to a lot of other critics.
- Yeah, I would say
the best critics online
are the ones where you
continue to keep watching
even though you disagree
with most of their opinions,
'cause their opinion holds,
even though you don't agree with it,
they explain it, and
they're articulate enough,
and they're honest enough
with what they like,
and the fact that there's no way
to completely get rid
of bias with anything.
And they own that.
And you're like, well, I knew
before coming into this review
that you were probably going to think
a certain way about it,
and I might not agree with it,
but I respect the fact that
you can still stick to this.
- Yeah, 'cause it's just like,
probably everything I like in a game
Connor's gonna complain about.
- Yeah, exactly.
And vice versa probably, right?
- Yeah, yeah, and vice versa, you know?
But that just comes
with our taste in games.
- Yeah, and that's fine.
- The same can be said
about anime and stuff.
I think I cut you off there.
- No, no, no, I don't know
what I was gonna even say.
Yeah, "Tokyo Revengers" was okay.
I really liked the first half,
and then it got really shit.
- And now, he's gonna have
"Tokyo Revengers" fans
on his throat.
- "Tokyo Revengers" was...
I saw the first four
episodes, and I'm just like,
this is a read-the-manga show.
- I definitely felt that.
- You know what I mean?
- 'Cause there's a fight at the end.
Have you watched all of...
Anyone watched all of it here?
- I watched the first two episodes.
- There's this fight that
goes on for fucking nine
or eight episodes at the end.
And it is the dumbest fight
I've ever seen in my life.
- That sounds like some Aizen shit, dude.
- It is literally the fight
of wait, there's more.
Something happens, wait, there's more.
Wait, there's more.
And it's like, this is stupid.
Just fucking resolve it.
This is ridiculous.
This isn't "Dragon Ball."
- It's like every "Dragon Ball" fight.
- This story has been somewhat concise.
Yeah, they drag on a
little bit here and there.
They have had some long fights,
but never more than four
or five episodes, I think.
It just felt like this
last fight in particular
just took the absolute piss
to the point where I was
like, this is just stupid.
And yeah, it had a good cliffhanger.
I was so bored for four episodes.
- But it doesn't matter, man.
All the characters are hot as fuck.
According to the fan base,
according to the fan base.
- They've got these characters.
Yeah, I like some of the
characters in the show.
My god, are so many of them insufferable.
God, I mean, I liked the show.
I thought it was good.
Fuck, man, I felt like it blew its load,
and it was making excuses.
- Is it even over?
Is it even over?
- No, no, it's not.
- It's not over, is it?
- It's not, it's not.
And I feel like where they
left it was pretty good,
and it might pick up.
It just felt like every single
time something happened,
it was like, oh my god, there's more.
Oh my god, there's more.
- I don't know, I know this
is gonna sound really unfair,
and this is totally my bias,
but I think I only managed to make it
through the first two or three episodes,
because I immediately
saw what kind of theming
they were going for with the story.
Just a bunch of dudes just fighting...
- And it's weird as well.
- Good stuff, but I hate the fact
that the moment I knew
where the story was heading,
in my head, I was immediately just like,
I'd just rather read "Baki" to be honest.
- I was kind of pissed off as well
that all of these kids are 13, 14.
I was like, why?
Just make them 17.
It would make the story so much more-
- [Joey] But isn't it
weird that you felt that-
- It would make so much more sense.
- But here's the thing.
Isn't it weird that you
felt that about that show?
And yet, you see Hanayama
Kaoru who's 14 years old,
and you're like, perfectly understandable,
have a nice day.
- For some reason, it checks out.
- Yeah, right, it's so weird
how it checks out though.
- I don't doubt it, right?
Because "Baki" never asks me once
to actually believe this
world is a real world.
It just completely is like, listen, bro,
this is literally like the equivalent
of an internet forum debate
where, can Goku beat Saitama?
That is "Baki."
It never once asks you to
be invested in this world,
whereas "Tokyo Revengers," for me,
felt like it was trying
to get me to get invested
in the gangs and the culture and stuff.
But at the same time, how
are you gonna make me believe
that this is how 13-year-olds
and 14-year-olds react,
that they drive motorcycles,
that they do all this shit,
that they're willing to
rob and kill each other.
If you made these kids 18,
they can still be in school.
All of this would still make sense.
Just do that.
Why? Why?
- That's basically 90% of anime,
where they don't need to be that age,
'cause nobody their age
actually acts like them.
- This is one where I actually felt
like it was to a massive detriment
that they were super young.
Every single plot point in the story-
- Because it just made
it unbelievable, right?
- Not so unbelievable, but
it made it so to the fact
that it's constantly asking you
to just have this level
of disbelief, to give it,
okay, I guess this is how
14-year-olds would react
and respond to this situation.
And it's like, just add on four years.
They're still in school.
This can work in college.
It all still works.
The universe totally works.
- It can work when
you're an adult as well.
- And now they can ride
motorcycles no question about it.
This is in Japan.
No one is breaking the law in Japan.
People don't even like...
The only law they break
is stealing umbrellas.
That's literally it, that's all they do.
They don't do nothing.
That's all they do.
- Pretty much.
Yeah, pretty much.
- How the fuck are they gonna
get a motorcycle at 13 here?
- I feel like, the last time I felt that,
when I felt like the characters
just weren't acting their age at all,
was when I watched "Erased."
- I was gonna say, I knew-
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "Erased" was just like...
Man, these five-year-olds.
How old were they, five, six?
- They were eight.
- They were nine, I think.
- They're nine-year-olds acting like-
- They're like, yes, using
the forms of relativity
and quantum mechanics,
we can actually predict
when we will reenter into
space-time continuum.
- They were more capable
than veteran detectives
in the force and all this shit.
And I'm just like, bruh,
these are nine-year-olds,
and they're acting like fucking adults.
- That's why I just
couldn't get into "Erased."
It's the exact same thing where I'm like,
this nine-year-old girl
is solving mysteries
that fucking 30-year veterans
couldn't fucking crack.
- I know we've ranted about
this before and stuff.
We've talked all about the age and stuff.
I do understand that, a lot
of shows, I don't give a fuck.
It's totally fine.
- It's fiction, it's whatever.
- It doesn't matter.
But again, there are
some shows like "Erased"
where I feel like doing
this is just completely
to the detriment of the show.
And it makes you suspend
belief beyond reasonable doubt.
I don't know, and this
was one of the shows
where I'm like, this is just stupid.
- I mean, there's also
"Your Lie in April" as well,
where a big thing that
took me out of the show
is I feel like they were in
middle school or something.
I think they're 14, 15.
Everyone talks like a fucking poet.
- The writing needs to match the age.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I don't give a shit if
you put 'em in the school.
You've gotta write
13-year-olds like 13-year-olds.
- Kosei was talking like
fucking Mozart was back then.
It's like, dude, you're 15.
When I was 15, all I was
thinking about poo-poo, pee-pee.
- That's all I think about now. I'm 25.
- That's all I think about now.
You are way more sophisticated
than you should be for a 15-year-old.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, this
guy came out the womb
speaking in sonnets and all this shit.
He was studying Shakespeare
by the age of three.
My god, that took me out so much.
It was a small thing,
but it was just like,
you could've easily made
them at a higher age
to make them feel like
they had the ability
to speak like this.
They were 14 years old.
That was the biggest thing that worried.
- It's annoying.
Sometimes, it's shows where they write
the characters like 17-year-olds.
They act and talk like 17-year-olds.
They behave like 17-year-olds.
Why not just make them
fucking 17-year-olds?
- That's why I think, to this day,
the most perfect example
of a perfectly aged,
a character's acting age appropriate
in a super realistic
way, was "Golden Time."
Because it was like, they were in college,
and yet they were super immature
like most college students are.
That's a realistic character.
- I like that show.
- I love "Golden Time."
- Yeah, and that's why
that show was so good,
and it was so immersive,
because it's like,
yeah, I know people who
are like this in college.
- You're such a breath of fresh air
to have it set in college.
- Yeah, but they were acting
more like high school students
than most high school
students were in other shows.
It's so fucking ironic.
- Yeah, I feel like that's
why, to me even now,
"Golden Time" is one of
my favorite romances-
- I love "Golden Time."
- In all of anime.
Just because it actually felt
like these were believable
characters set in a world
that felt like it was based in reality,
not in this anime world
where 15-year-olds-
- 15-year-olds are doing quantum physics.
I mean, you look at fucking
Naruto and Sasuke, they-
- "Hunter x Hunter" was another one
where I felt like they
got the characters' ages,
it actually reflected their personality.
Gon was an idiot.
He would be convinced to
do stuff by strangers.
- Right, right.
- Like a 12-year-old-
- Like a child.
- Like a 13-year-old, unfortunately.
No one over the age of 18
is hanging out with Hisoka,
you know what I mean?
Let's be honest.
- For good reason.
- [All] For a good reason.
- 'Cause everyone could
tell you he's a creep.
But Gon is like-
- For their own protection.
- Gon's like, oh, he's talking to me.
Okay, I'll talk back.
I appreciate it when shows actually treat
the characters like their age.
It pissed me off.
- 'Cause a lot of people,
for example, Naruto,
a lot of people forget
that, in the OG "Naruto,"-
- He's 10.
- They're 11 and 12 years old.
You look at some of the
shit they go through.
Sasuke is trying to revenge
his entire fucking clan
at the age of 11.
11!
He's doing that, right?
- This man's listened to too
much My Chemical Romance, dude.
- Right, right, right.
- Get off that shit,
and go to fucking hell.
- I'll avenge my fucking Big Mac
if someone slaps it out
of my hand when I'm 11.
So I believe that actually.
I was a very petty 11-year-old.
- Most realistic character.
- I don't know, man.
I just kinda wish that it
would change a little bit.
And that was one of the main reasons
why I was a bit harsh
on "Tokyo Revengers."
And that's why I got more annoyed with it,
'cause it felt like it was just
getting stupid right there.
- I don't know if I've
just seen so much anime
that I'm just immune to this shit.
It's very rare that a
character's age really comes
into any kind of specific plot point
or any bearing on the plot itself.
It's so hard to tell a
character's age in anime
based on just their
looks and their actions,
because the range of anime
characters from 13 to fucking 28,
they all look the same,
and they all act the same.
- They act the same, yeah.
- It's kinda like Japanese
people in real life, isn't it?
- Maybe that's why!
Maybe that's why!
- That's probably why.
- Right, right.
- They turn to adults-
- You look at a Japanese girl,
and you're like, you can be 12 or 30.
And I'm kind of afraid to ask.
- Did you see, as well,
for the "Tokyo Revengers,"
they made an uncensored version?
Because they used the temple symbol a lot,
which is unfortunately is-
- A manji?
- A swastika turned.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Really unfortunate, and then they just-
- They had to censor that?
- They made a censored version-
- Oh, damn.
- Where they just don't use
the symbol much.
- 'Cause it's in the title.
- Yeah, it's weird.
In some ways, I'm like,
I mean, I feel like they
didn't need to do that,
but I also kinda get it, why
they wanted to be careful.
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
- Yeah, I mean, I can
see why they did that.
It's unfortunate, but I mean,
with how international anime is now,
a lot of people could've
taken it the wrong way,
because they don't have-
- Also, it may be a good moment
to learn about another culture.
- Yeah, right, be like,
why are they using that?
- Yeah, you'd be like, what the fuck?
I'm gonna Google, is this okay?
And then you see it.
To me, when I first saw
it, I was like, whoa.
And then you Google it,
and you're like, oh, okay.
- It's only been a symbol
that's been around for,
I don't know, 3,000 years.
- It's been a lot longer,
yeah, it's very unfortunate.
- Didn't they censor
it in "Naruto" as well?
'Cause I remember Neji's clan symbol
that he had on his forehead or something
was originally based on that, I believe.
- I don't know.
- There's a lot of shows
that I think use those symbols.
- Well, yeah, 'cause it means-
- It means peace.
- Yeah, peace, oddly enough.
- Yeah, it means peace.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's Buddhist, right?
It's very unfortunate, the
dichotomy of the meanings.
- [Ashley] Oh, no, Neji has a cross.
- Oh, it's a cross? Okay.
- Unless that's the censored version.
- Wait, is that the anime
version or the manga version?
- [Ashley] It was the anime version.
- Okay, so-
- So the manga version might've had it.
- What was the manga version of that?
- [Ashley] Let me check.
- So they made a whole
version where they added it,
and then a whole 'nother version
where they just went
through and got rid of it.
Really odd.
- [Joey] Nevermind all the violence.
- I feel like, if you're
just gonna get rid of it,
just get rid of it.
- Yeah, exactly, right.
- It's not gonna be that big of a deal.
- Here's the uncensored one
for you cultured individuals out there.
- Cultured?
- Actually cultured in
a different religion.
- [Ashley] Yeah, so in the manga,
it was literally the manji sign.
- Yeah, that's what I thought,
that's what I thought.
- [Ashley] That's in the anime.
- I get it, if you wanna
avoid the misunderstanding.
- I get it, yeah.
- Have the awkward, guys,
we promise, look it up.
- We promise, not a Nazi.
- [Ashley] It's the same thing
with the Google Maps issue though.
They changed the manji sign.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah,
because on Google Maps,
they use that symbol to mean temple.
- I have that on mine.
I have an English Google Maps.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah, it's there.
- Yeah, yeah, it's on there for me.
- Maybe on the other languages?
I swear to God, on my
Google Maps in English,
I still see the symbol.
- [Ashley] Because it was an
issue a couple of years back,
because it was like, what
is this on the Google Maps?
- Maybe if you're not
in Japan, and you search
up Japanese places.
- I feel like it's on
the person who comes to
Japan to educate themselves.
- Kind of.
- Yeah, because they're the ones
that're gonna throw a hissy
fit and look like an idiot.
- Yeah, I understand it's
a very unfortunate thing,
obviously, with whom Japan
allied themselves with.
I can understand why the
mistake might be made.
- It's scary how 45
degrees changes everything.
It's just a slight shift,
just completely changes everything.
- The power of 45 degrees.
- The power of angles.
(Garnt laughs)
The powers of angles, dude, scary.
- You either want peace,
or you want something
that's definitely not that.
- Definitely the opposite of peace.
- [Ashley] Buddhism, I
took a class on this,
Buddhism doesn't actually distinguish
between the orientation
and which direction
the swastika is facing.
So technically, all of them mean the same.
- Right.
- Right, right.
- But yeah, I mean, most people
wouldn't know that though.
- Obviously, when I saw
it, I didn't feel like,
oh my god, what is this?
I was just like, oh, what don't I know?
Clearly, I'm missing context.
I would like to be educated.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I felt exactly the same way.
I was just like, it's
weird seeing that symbol,
but I'm sure they would not be-
- There's a good reason for that.
- I'm sure they wouldn't
be putting that symbol
if there wasn't a reason for that.
- I'm sure these 13-year-olds,
this gang, is not into that.
I mean, I mean.
I mean, I know that's a gang.
- See, if only everyone
on the internet thought,
had rational thinking like that, you know?
And instead, it was immediately
like, oh no, how dare you!
- We've said it a number of times.
People aren't willing to give
the benefit of the
doubt to people anymore.
That's gone out the
window in the year 2022.
- Also, they forget
that different cultures
have different backgrounds and
histories a lot of the times.
- That's what's strange is
that people don't really
wanna give benefit of
the doubt to the country
or even hide behind their country's flaws
when it's convenient for them.
But when they don't understand something,
they're like, oh, well,
you know what I mean?
I don't know, I don't know.
- They should've explained it better.
- Anyway, keeping on anime, I guess,
I guess, since I finally
get to talk about anime.
- Go on.
- I didn't actually watch much
anime this previous season,
because I don't think there
was actually much good things.
- Oh, god, don't say that.
Everyone would get angry.
There's no good anime last season.
- Yeah, have you not learned my lesson?
- 2021, well, I think 2022
he's been a pretty weak year
for anime so far.
I guess the only real
recommendation I would have,
since you were going through last year,
is "Ranking of Kings."
- That's literally the last one
I've been meaning to watch of last year,
and then I'm done with last year.
- I mean, it's continuing onto this year.
Last year was, I mean,
it's a 23-episode show.
So last year, we only had 12 episodes.
- Oh, I mean, I guess I'll just wait then.
- Just wait till it's finished?
- Yeah, I mean-
- I mean, it's almost finished.
I feel like it's only gonna
be a part one of the story.
But yeah, "Ranking of Kings"
is fucking incredible.
- I've heard it's amazing.
- Yeah, it's like, unironically,
a lot of people, like "Made
in Abyss," didn't watch it,
'cause it looked like
a children's cartoon.
- No, it looked badass.
- I also didn't watch it,
'cause it looked like a
children's cartoon initially,
but it's kind of like,
it's kinda like the closest
thing to a Ghibli movie,
I guess, in terms of aesthetic.
- Yeah, it looked beautiful.
- And feeling.
I really don't like Ghibli movies,
but it kinda gave me that kind of...
You know when you're
watching an anime fairy tale
that kinda feels like-
- Yeah.
- I can only point to Ghibli
that gives you that same kinda feeling,
but that's the kind of
feeling it's giving me.
But it also is written
really, really fucking well.
It's been a while since
I've seen just an anime
just this well written
and with characters this
interesting as well.
- [Joey] Damn.
- To me, the spring season,
no, sorry, the winter season,
was basically "Attack on
Titan" and "Demon Slayer."
Everyone was talking about that.
To me, "Ranking of Kings"
is close to that level
of quality, in my opinion,
of just how good the show is.
- Well, I mean, there's also
"My Dress-Up Darling" as well.
- There was also "My Dress-Up Darling."
That occupies a different
space in my opinion.
- That's a different faction, I feel.
- That's a different faction.
- Yeah, true, true, true.
There's the "Attack of
Titan" "Demon Slayer" core,
and then the fucking "My Dress-Up Darling"
all the way over here.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was surprising to see, in Japan,
"Ranking of Kings" has
really shot up in popularity.
I think it's the most
watched anime right now.
- It's because there's
a lot of voice actors
who are saying how good it is.
They're all like, "Yeah,
this is really fucking good."
- Voice actors have a lot of power here.
- Yeah, they do, I mean.
- They're top-tier celebrities here.
- Yeah, they're not even
just voice actors here.
They're just actors with-
- Celebrities.
- They're just gone to
celebrity status as well.
- And that's why they can
make questionable decisions
like Hanazawa Kana selling NFTs, you know?
- [Connor] Oh, god.
- I saw that, and I was
like, this has to be a joke.
And then I watched the video-
- Please say psych.
- I was like, please say
psych, Hana Kana, please.
- And I saw a lot of
people that were like,
no, no, no, I'm sure
it's just her management.
I'm sure it's just her management.
And I'm like, yeah, but-
- But she agreed to it.
- Yeah, someone has to give the go ahead.
Even if it is her
management's idea or whatever-
- Yeah, she might have a management,
but she's allowed to say no.
- I love that.
No one ever uses that excuse
for Western celebrities or anything.
It's always with the Japanese celebrities.
- I feel that only implies
to kind of low ranking talent
who maybe where the management
has a little more power,
because we're giving you this one.
- [Connor] Yeah, the big
ones don't have that.
- Hana Kana is literally
top 1% of voice actors.
She can say no to whatever
the fuck she wants.
- She don't need no NFTs.
- And yet, she said yes
to the NFTs.
- She takes any role she wants.
- She can do any role she wants.
If she says, "I wanna be in this anime,"
the directors will be
scrambling over themselves
to be like, yes, let's
get Hana Kana in this.
The whole management
thing is just bullshit.
- NFTs, no.
- That is just Hana Kana fans in denial
of the fact that she's promoting NFTs.
- That is just her fans
snorting pure Copium.
I've never seen so much Copium.
- I saw so much Copium being huffed, dude.
- Oh my god.
- It was insane.
Insane amounts of Copium, dude.
- I think there's never been...
One of my favorite memes is just like,
I think it's a coomer
image of just, thing.
And there's just a depressed guy.
And just, Japanese thing,
and it's just him
lighting him up, you know?
Have you seen that image?
- Yeah, I love that.
- It's so true that.
- There's never been-
- It's so true.
- A time where an image
is more pertinent than this time.
- The other version of that that I love
is every Instagram post,
it's like, somewhere.
And it's really dark.
And it's like, somewhere, Japan.
- I mean, that's basically
the Trash Taste podcast
in a nutshell.
- Literally, yeah.
- But no, I remember seeing that post,
and I was just like, why
did it have to be you?
Why did it have to be you?
- Right, if it was some D-tier,
I voiced one passing by
A person selling an NFT,
I would be like, what the fuck ever.
But you're literally one
of the most notable voice actors today.
- Is this how idol fans felt
when their favorite idol
gets through a controversy,
or they find out they have
a boyfriend or something?
I think I get it now, man.
I felt betrayed, you know?
Why did it have to be you, Kana Hanazawa?
- I'm not even mad.
I'm just disappointed.
- Yeah, right, I'm just disappointed.
- Come on, man.
- I thought we were better than this.
Yeah, it was disappointing.
Yeah, I haven't seen anyone
talking about it since.
I just saw it on my timeline,
and I'm just like, well, that sucks.
- There were a lot of even
Japanese people on Twitter
just being like, no, no, this ain't it.
- Yeah, how did Japanese
twitter react to it?
- Basically the same as
how Western Twitter was.
- Really?
- There were like, dude, why?
Why you of all people?
- Bro moment, bro moment.
- Yeah, it was a bro moment, yeah.
- Well, that's been your
weekly reminder that NFTs suck.
- Yep, you know who else
doesn't conform to NFTs though?
Our patrons.
- Oh my god, wonderful, wonderful.
- They could use that money
to do all sorts of NFT stuff,
but thank god they don't.
Instead they're using
it to support this show.
- The boys!
- Yeah, the boys.
- Their wallets out for the boys.
Thank you very much.
Hey, if you like to pull
the wallets out for the boys
and support the show,
then go up to our Patreon,
Patreon.com/trashtaste,
also follow us on Twitter.
Send us your memes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
- Yeah, that's been your
yearly anime discussion
on our one episode of Trash Taste.
- See you next year!
- See you next year, boys,
for a 20-minute anime discussion.
- All right, see you next week. Bye.
- [Garnt And Connor] Bye.
(relaxing music)